MA'AM THE COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN-COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING A COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH ALL MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN PERSON THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT TO USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU SPEAK BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY. TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE-REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS. WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. BEFORE WE
BEGIN OF HEY WE ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM. WELL THE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BROWSER
HERE GROW. CORTESE NEWMAN YOUR.
WHEN SHE COMES BACK WILL ASK
YOU TO CONTINUE THE ROLL CALL
OKAY- IN TODAY'S HEARING WE
WILL REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS REGARDING LABOR WORK
FORCE DEVELOPMENT AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT ALL
VOTES WILL BE TAKEN AT THE END
OF THE HEARING ONCE WE HAVE
COMPLETED ALL DISCUSSION AND
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION
OF OUR PRESENTATION ON ISSUE
NINE HIGH ROAD OUR ROADS.
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP. AND I
THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS R. S.
THE DEPARTMENT. TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION YES THANK YOU
SENATOR MADAM CHAIR THIS IS JIM
RAINEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE SKEWS
ME WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
POLLS OPEN FOR ANY YOU. SIX TO
DO SEVERAL THINGS AT. YOU FOR
EXPAND WORK. IN ACCESS TO
APPRENTICESHIP EXPANDING
APPRENTICESHIP ACCESS TO
APPRENTICESHIPS SPECIALLY IN
THE IN THE TRADES ARE IN
LEARNED BURKE BOTH MOVING
PEOPLE UP AND MOVING PEOPLE IN
UPSKILL BACKFILL I ENTERED
ENTRY LEVEL AND THEN OF COURSE
SUPPORTING. PEOPLE WALK WHILE
THEY'RE IN TRAINING ESPECIALLY
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
UPPORTING FAMILIES AND CAN'T
DROP EVERYTHING TO PARTAKE IN
TRAINING GENERALLY SO THEY NEED
SUPPORT AND INCLUDING INCOME.
ARE YOU REAL QUICKLY. THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES. I TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS HI THIS IS
TO EXPAND EXISTING HIGHROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS AND HIERO
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS ARE ALSO
CREATING NEW PROJECTS IN
SECTORS THAT HAVE LOTS OF JOB
OPENINGS ACCORDING TO THE DATA
THAT WE LOOKED AT. THE FIRST IS
EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS WE HAVE
THE EXISTING PROJECT
PARTNERSHIPS IN EVERY CORNER OF
CALIFORNIA BETTER CREATING
ACCESS TO STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THROUGH
PRE OF PRINTERS RIDERSHIP
FOCUSED ON YOUNG ADULTS
EDUCATED WORKERS- JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS- AND
OTHERS- WE HAVE A LEADING
CURRENT HIRING CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS PARTNERSHIPS AS I SAID
IN EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA
THE REGIONALLY BASED IN THEIR
CREATING PATHWAYS TO. SOME OF
THE BEST MIDDLE CLASS JOBS-
BLUE COLLAR MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA- THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS- THESE
ARE NON CONSTRUCTION SECTOR
PARTNERSHIPS. FOCUSED ON FOUR
SECTORS FOR STRING AGRICULTURE
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
HEALTH CARE AND DENTAL FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TRADING
LOGISTICS FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. IF I COULD
JUST QUICKLY ON THE HIGH ROAD-
BECAUSE IT COMES UP A LOT I
WANT TO JUST CRIED VERY QUICKLY
MAKE THAT MAKE IT CLEAR WHAT
THE DEFINITION IS THAT WE USE
WHEN APPLYING IT TO- THIS WORK-
IT IS ABOUT WORKFORCE THE
HIGHROAD. AS ABOUT WORKFORCE
BUT THE PRINCIPLES ARE ALSO
APPLIED MORE BROADLY. THOSE THE
PRIMARY ONES PRINCIPLES ARE JOB
QUALITY. A WORKER VOICE IN
AGENCY. EQUITY ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY AFTER JOB
QUALITY THAT THE- APPROACH IS
TO IDENTIFY THE BEST JOBS IN
SECTORS THEY'RE DRIVING.
REGIONAL EMPLOYMENT AND THEN
SUPPORT COMPANIES IN THOSE
SECTORS THAT ARE INVESTING IN
WORKERS THAT CARE ABOUT
COMMUNITIES I CARE ABOUT THE
LONG TERM. I DEVELOPING A
TALENT IN INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT
REGIONALLY BASED. UP THE DNA OF
THIS HIRING APPROACH IS
INDUSTRY ENGAGEMENT SO CREATING
THE CONDITIONS. FOR GREATER
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
RESKILLING A JOB IN INCOME
ABILITY AND INCREASE PATHWAYS.
INTO GOOD JOBS FROM A WORKERS
THAT'S OUR UPSKILL BACKFILL.
CONCEPT WHICH SOUNDS PRETTY
WONKY- WORKER VOICE IN
AGENCIES. AS YOU WELL KNOW
SENATOR. WORKERS OFTEN THE BEST
ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE EFFICIENCY
AND PRODUCTIVITY- THEY NEED A
SEAT AT THE TABLE ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO. CHANGING
TECHNOLOGY IN THE FUTURE
WORKING AS WE'VE SEEN WITH
COATED. WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES OF COURSE OF ART. MOST
AT RISK OF CHANGE- EQUITY IS
THE THIRD ONE. THE CONCERT IS
REALLY QUARTER THIS IS YOU
CAN'T ACHIEVE WITHOUT JOB
QUALITY MOST LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
ALREADY WORK OUT THERE THE
WORKING POOR SO WE HAVE TO BE
DELIVERED ABOUT CONNECTING
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. TO GOOD
QUALITY JOBS AND THEN FINALLY%
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY
WORKING WITH THOSE INDUSTRY
SECTORS AND COMMUNITIES AND
WORKERS. COURT THE FRONT LINES
ON THE FRONT LINES OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND OUR EFFORTS TO PULL
CARBON OUT OF THE ATMOSPHERE
AND GET TO- LONG TERM- BATH
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY. THANKYOU
SENATOR GREAT- THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. HI A I'M
ARGUMENT IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT- I THAT DID THE-
REQUEST IS A CURRENT YOUR
REQUEST TAKING ON BE ON PAGE
EIGHTEEN OF THE HAND OUT- IT'S-
IT'S SLATED FOR BUDGET YEAR
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT IT'S A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. ONE TIME IN THE CURRENT
YEAR TO EXPAND HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP STATEWIDE AND THE
INTENSE- AS MYSTERY HAD
EXPLAINED THIS TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S QUICK ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- IN RESPONSE TO THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE
ECONOMY BY INVESTING IN
EXISTING. AND NEW PROJECTS THAT
CAN SCALE QUICKLY HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THE L. A- PLEASE.
ACCORDING TO ALTHOUGH THE
LATEST AND OFFICE WE HAVE
NOTICED. CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL- REITERATING AGAIN
THAT IT'S ONE OF THE EARLY
ACTION ITEMS FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR. THE HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP IN RECENT YEARS HAS
BECOME SORT OF THE STATE'S.
FLAGSHIP WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ONE OF
THE COMMENTS IN THAT THE STAFF
OF GENDER THAT WE- SORT OF ONE
OF THOSE WHAT. IS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
JUST GETTING A SENSE FOR.
LONGER TERM AS THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO EXPAND ON THAT THE
STATE IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW ITS
OUTCOMES AND TO MAKE ANY
ADJUSTMENTS ARE NEEDED THANK
YOU. THE YOU MISTER RANEY COULD
YOU RESPOND TO THE L. A. O.'S
COMMENTS PLEASE. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- ABSOLUTELY MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE SENATE AND YOUR
STAFF MADAM CHAIR I'M LOOKING
AT OUTCOMES LONGER TERM FOR THE
HIRING TRAINING- PARTNERSHIP
WORK WE ALSO DO A VALUATION
WORK ON ALL OF OUR PROJECTS
INCLUDING THE HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS- FOR H. R. T. P.
IT'S GARC OUR EVALUATION WE'RE
CURRENTLY GHOSTED THROUGH UCLA.
UCLA LABOR CENTER. OKAY WE'LL
JUST FOR ME I'LL START OUT WITH
A COUPLE OF COMMENTS- I'M
REALLY GLAD TO SEE THE SECTOR
WORK. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT IS
DOING- I AS I WENT THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT SECTORS THAT YOU ARE
COVERING OR PROPOSED TO COVER
AND THAT YOU HAVE COVERED- I
SEE THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
SECTORS THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED
AND I'M WONDERING. WHY THE
PROPOSAL WOULD NOT INCLUDE-
WHAT ARE THE SERVICE
INDUSTRIES- AND THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY THEY'RE TWO OF THE
HARDEST HIT IN THIS PANDEMIC.
AND CERTAINLY- HOSPITALITY WILL
COME BACK BUT IT'S A MATTER OF
WHEN- I'VE NOTICED OF THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS. THAT
FOOD SERVICE IS BEING. DONE AS
A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC- BUT
WE ARE STILL NVESTING IN FOOD
SERVICE FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE
AND COUNTIES AND I THINK CITIES
ARE. MANY AT MANY LEVELS-
THEY'VE BEEN REPURPOSED SO.
JUST GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE L. A.
U. S. D. DISTRIBUTED MILLIONS
OF MEALS. TO THE STUDENTS AND
TWO ADULTS IN THEIR AND THEIR
FAMILIES- SO SOMEWHERE THOSE.
OF MEALS WERE PRODUCED THEY
WERE MADE AND PUT TOGETHER AND
THEN THEY WERE DELIVERED AND
THEN THEY WERE DISTRIBUTED SO
THERE'S A DIFFERENT VERSION OF
HOW OUR FOOD NEEDS ARE ARE
BEING MET- THE SO I'M JUST
WONDERING- WHAT IS IT THAT
COULD BE DONE IN THE PROPOSED
MONEY- TO PARTNER WITH THESE.
NEW OR RE PURPOSED OR DIFFERENT
VERSION OF THE THESE SECTORS. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT'S IT
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT A
GREAT QUESTION- WE DID FOCUS ON
THIS INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT THE DATA AGAIN
THAT HAD A LOT OF JOB OPENINGS
AND NOW- IN IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE THE INTENT IS TO GET. A
QUICK EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN IMPACTED BY COVERED
IN THE RESULTING ECONOMIC
FALLOUT- I THINK THAT'S AN
AMAZING POINT YOU MAKE. THE
HOSPITALITY SECTOR- ALONG WITH
BUILDING MAINTENANCE ARE TO
THAT WERE HIT EARLY AS YOU SAY-
AND HIT HARD- AND MOSTLY
IMPACTED LOW INCOME WORKERS-
AND IMMIGRANTS PEOPLE OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY- AND I AGREE WITH
YOU COMPLETELY WE HAVE A HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP. IN BOTH
THOSE SECTORS ABILITY SKILLS
PARTNERSHIP. IN BUILDING
MAINTENANCE- THAT IS RETRAINING
BILLING SERVICE WORKERS INCO
THE DISINFECTION OF YOUR
CREATIVE- AND FORWARD LOOKING
WAY OF NOT JUST MEETING. THE
MOMENT- BUT ALSO DOING IN A WAY
THAT RETRAINS WORKERS FOR- TO
STAY EMPLOYED. THE HOSPITALITY
SECTOR IN LOS ANGELES ACTUALLY
IS THERE'S A HIGHER A
PARTNERSHIP THE COR THERE ARE
YOU NOT YOUR ELEVEN- AND HOTEL
PROPERTIES AND EVENT VENUES
WORKING TOGETHER AND THAT HIGH
ROAD PARTNERSHIP IT'S ONE OF
OUR OUR FLAGSHIP PROJECTS IN
FACT. APPROVED RESILIENT
THROUGH THAT PARTNERSHIP- SO
THEY KEPT- AS YOU AS YOU
POINTED OUT LARGE INDUSTRIAL
SIZED KITCHENS OPERATING TO
PROVIDE- FOOD RELIEF AND I
THINK THEY REACH TEN THOUSAND
PLUS- A SENIOR'S HOME BOUND
SENIORS AND PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS GOT THREE THOUSAND
OR THREE MILLION. MEALS COOKED
AND DELIVERED TO HOMES WORKING
WITH- TAXING AIRPORT SHUTTLE
COMPANIES SO. WELL OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE. PUT BACK
TO WORK AND LAUGHS WERE
PREVENTED THROUGH THIS VERY
CREATIVE WAY OF AGAIN MEETING
THE MOMENT- AND I ALSO AGREE TO
THESE THE SECTORS THAT WERE HIT
HARD AND EARLY OR IN TRANSITION
AND I THINK THERE. WE NEED TO
REALLY FOCUS ON EXPANDING- AND
INVESTING IN THOSE IN THAT
CREATIVITY THAT MARKET CREATION-
BECAUSE AS- CODES CAN AND
PEOPLE GO BACK. ADVANCE
BUILDINGS WORK OFFICES
RESTAURANTS HOTELS CONVENTIONS
ALL THAT IS GOING TO COME BACK
WE HAVE TO BEPREPARED. I ALSO
THINK THAN TERMS OF THE
CONVERSATIONS- THERE IS- ISSUES
AT THE PORTS- A CONVERSATION
SHOULD BE HAD AT THE PORTS
ABOUT AUTOMATION AND OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE IMPACTING-
THOSE GOOD JOBS SO I WONDER IF
WE COULD. CONTINUE OR- HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
HOPEFULLY THEY LEAD TO OF A
REAL OF PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
EMPLOYERS AND WATCHING OUT FOR
THOSE THOSE GOOD JOBS AS WELL.
YES ABSOLUTELY A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF FUTURE OF FUTURE OF WORK AND
LABOR MANAGEMENT WORKING
TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF AUTOMATION ARE
AND HOW TO HOW TO DEAL WITH IN
WAYS IT REALLY PROTECT
COMMUNITIES IN THE WORK FORCE
SO I'M REALLY HAPPY TO WORK
WITH WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR IN
YOUR STAFF. ON ON THOSE ITEMS
YES MAYBE CALL IT TRANSITION
SECTORS OR SOMETHING THAT SHOWS
THAT WE'RE NOT A 100% CLEAR HOW
IT'S ALL GONNA LAND BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT JOBS CONTINUE
TO BE CREATED IN THAT
DIRECTION. OKAY ANY. SENATORS
AND COMMON OR QUESTIONS- YES
CENTER ANYWAY- BEFORE A MYSTERY
MYSTERY GOOD TO SEE YOU- I HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS RELATED
TO. THAT THE SEVEN HOUSES WE
GOT REFERENCES A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS OVER. FOUR
BUDGET IN SUPPORT OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRESS ON
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE CAN YOU GIVE US
SOME INSIGHT INTO THE SPECIFICS
OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT YOU KNOW
HOW DOES THAT HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS BREAK DOWN.
WHAT KIND OF JOBS ARE THESE AND
ADD TO WHAT HOW DO YOU MEASURE
SUCCESS AGAINST THAT LARGER
OBJECTIVE OF GREENHOUSE. GAS
REDUCTION. THANK YOU SENATORS
IS GREAT TO SEE YOU TOO- WE
MISS YOU ON THE STATE WORKFORCE
BOARD. THANK YOU. SB SIX WEEKS.
THE OTHER GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS THAT WERE OUT-
ALLOCATED TO THIS THE STATE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD-
WERE ACTUALLY CUT BACK DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THERE WAS LESS
REVENUE THROUGH CAP AND TRADE.
IN THAT PROGRAM SO- WE DID PUT
UP ALL OF THE MONEY THAT WAS
ALLOCATED TO THE STATE
WORKFORCE BOARD OUT IN
COMPETITIVE- GRANTS- AND WE'VE
JUST- APPROVED THE FIRST
ROUNDERS GRANTS AND THEY'RE
LOOKING AT. A VERY SECTORS THAT
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
CLIMATE- WE'RE EXPANDING WORK
IN TRANSIT IN FACT BECAUSE
TRANSIT IT IS EXPANDING. A NEW
VEHICLES ARE BEING ADDED TO
TRANSIT FLEETS THAT ARE ZERO
EMISSION BUSES. SO RETRAINING
WORKERS WHO ARE DOING
MAINTENANCE ON THOSE BUSES AND
ALSO MECHANICS ISREALLY
CRITICAL SO A LOT OF TREE
TRAINING GOING ON A TRANSIT
THAT'S PART OF IT- THERE'S A
PROJECT THAT IS LOOKING AT THE
MANUFACTURE OF. CLEAN FUEL
BUSES- IN LOS ANGELES AND
LOOKING TO EXPAND AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE- SO IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL OUT FOR.
PULLING CARBON OUT OF THE
ATMOSPHERE OF COURSE REDUCING
CARBON INTO THE ATMOSPHERE-
THE- BUILDING SKILLS
PARTNERSHIP- PROJECT THAT I
MENTIONED- WITH THE BILLING
WITH- IN LOS ANGELES BUT
ACTUALLY STATEWIDE. WITH S.
YEAH YOU- UNITED BY. SERVICE
WORKERS. ARE IN A NUMBER OF-
PROPERTIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THEY'RE DOING NOT JUST CALL THE
DISINFECTION TRAINING- BUT
THEY'RE ALSO DOING A GREEN
JANITORS TRAINING PROGRAM WHICH
IS HELPING THOSE. LEAD A
BUILDINGS ARE MEET THOSE GOALS
OF REDUCING ENERGY- INCREASING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY SO THOSE ARE
A FEW EXAMPLES OF THE KINDS OF
WORK. THAT ARE PART OF A
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND.
INVESTMENTS AND I THE I THINK
THAT. THE POINT THAT WE'VE
MADE- PRIOR TO THAT MONEY COME
TO THE STATE WORKFORCE BOARD.
IS YOU CAN'T. THAT MEET THE
GOALS THAT THE IT REALLY. A
GOALS CAL HAS THREE. CLIMB
CHANGE- WITH THE WAY FORCE DO
THAT WORK ACROSS THE ACROSS THE
BOARD. INCLUDING STANDING UP
UTILITY SCALE SOLAR AND WIND-
AND OTHER RENEWABLE SO
EFFICIENCY IN REPAIRING OVALS
WE HAVE TO INVEST IN THE
WORKFORCE. APPRECIATE THAT SIR
SO AGAIN THIS IS RELATIVELY NEW
FOR ME MAYBE FOR OTHERS SO IF
YOU COULD YOU KNOW GUESTS THAT
SAY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
MEASURE. SUCCESS LIKE WHAT
METRICS DO YOU USE OVER TIME-
TO ASCERTAIN YEAH BECAUSE THE
RETURN ON THOSE INVESTMENTS.
BOB THIS IS A REALLY GREAT YES
REALLY QUICK QUESTION WE FOLLOW
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD'S
GUIDELINES. ON HOW TO MEASURE-
AGAINST THE- THE GOALS AROUND
REDUCING GAS IS A GREENHOUSE
GASES- AND SO I. HONESTLY WOULD
HAVE TO DEFER TO THE- RESOURCES
BOARDING CAN GET BACK TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ON EXACTLY WHAT
THOSE MEASURES ARE- WE ALSO OF
COURSE LOOK AT. RETRAINING IN
TRAINING OF WORKERS OF BUILDING
A MORE RESILIENT WORKFORCE
INSIDE THE SECTORS- AND THEN
CREATING ACCESS TO TWO JOBS.
BUT ALSO THEY'RE ALWAYS HIGH
QUALITY GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT
CAN SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. SO OUR METRICS ON
THAT WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
EASILY SHAPE THEY'RE THEY'RE
QUITE GOOD. AT ANY EQUITY
OUTCOMES ARE ALSO QUITE GOOD
YEAH I SHOULD BE QUITE GRATEFUL
FOR THE A. R. V. TO TAKE ON
THIS RIGHT JUST FOR MY OWN
EDIFICATION SO. THANK YOU
VENTURE. I THINK THAT'S A VERY
GOOD YES SENATOR. IS A ONE JOB
YOU EVER SINCE. THE TURN
RECOGNIZED- I JUST THOUGHT THAT
WAS A GREAT QUESTION IS
WONDERFUL EVAN GET
CLARIFICATION- LET ME LET ME
SAY FIRST- BUT- I DISTRIBUTED
INFORMATION TO EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
ALL INTERESTED IN IT AND
APPRECIATE THE SENATE EVEN
ASKING FOR IT- QUESTION I JUST
I'M NOT SURE I LISTENED CLOSELY
ENOUGH. IN ADDITION TO. THE
WORKFORCE TRAINING TO GET
PEOPLE TO DO THE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE USING GENDER
SYSTEM EXAMPLE I'M ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR ON THAT IS THERE ALSO
DOES ANY OF THIS MONEY. GO
TOWARD- WORKFORCE TRANSITION AS
WELL IN A WHICH IS A BIG ISSUE
IN THIS IN THIS SPACE IN THIS
AREA FOR US I THINK
LEGISLATIVELY AS- WE CAN PUT
ALL THE DETAIL IN THE WORLD.
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF. THE
ELEMENTS AND COMPONENTS OF READ
REDUCING GHG. HELLO WHAT KIND
OF THINGS WE NEED TO DO WITH
BUILDINGS AT CETERA- BUT- TO
DONE AS MUCH WORK IN ON THE
METRICS OF- TO THE EXTENT THAT
WERE DISPLACED THAT. THOSE
SUCCESSES DISPLACED WORKERS-
WHAT WE DO ABOUT THAT AND I'M
JUST WONDERING TO WHAT EXTENT
IF AT ALL YOU'VE TAKEN OUT OF-
YEAH WE LOOKED AT THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER IT'S A
GREAT ONE- WE'VE LOOKED AT
THAT-WE WERE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY. WITH THAT THE SEVERAL
STATE ENTITIES ON JUST THOSE
QUESTIONS OF TRANSITION SO
TARGETING SECTORS THAT ARE MOST
IMPACTED. BY THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GASES- AND WHAT'S
GONNAHAPPEN TO THOSE THAT WORK
FOR SO THERE'S A LOT OF
RESEARCH GOING ON. AT SO WE CAN
TARGET OUR- OUR INVESTMENTS IN
WAYS THAT HELP. RETOOL WORKERS
IN RESPONSE TO THAT SO OUR
INTENTION IS TO KEEP WORKERS.
WHO ARE MAKING GOOD WAGES
BECAUSE GOOD WAGES ARE ARE
DRIVING. THE ECONOMIES OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THAT ARE VERY
DEPENDENT ON FOSSIL FUEL BASED
INDUSTRIES- SO OUR INTENTION IS
ALWAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE
PRESERVE JOBS HE PEOPLE IN GOOD
QUALITY JOBS TO KEEP THAT MONEY
FLOWING IN COMMUNITIES. ONE WAY
WE DO THAT IS THROUGH.
INCREASED INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE- SO ABOUT
BUILDING MORE BUILDING STANDING
UP MORE- USUALLY SCALE SOLAR
AND WIND. IN OTHER PACKED TYPE
RENEWABLE PROJECTS OR
INCREASING ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
BUILDINGS. SO WE DO A LOT OF
WORK WITH THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES BOB CREATING PATHWAYS
INTO STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP. ARTISAN ALL OF
THAT PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
WORK. IS PUBLIC WORKS- AND THE
WORKERS THEY ARE DISPATCHED
THROUGH A HIRING HALL SEE THE
TRADES SO WHAT WE DO- A LOT IS
BUILDING PATHWAYS INTO THOSE A-
GROUP PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS. BUT
IT TO THE EXTENT WE SCALE THOSE
UP. THEN I THINK IT'S MUCH
EASIER TO TRANSITION WORKERS
WHO ARE IMPACTED TWO OTHER GOOD
HIGH WAGE JOBS. THANK YOU JUST
A FOLLOW. UP- OKAY IN A- ONE I
WHAT I'M WILL TO I THINK SOME.
IN THIS IS ONE SENATOR
SPEAKING- WE NEED MORE FORMALLY
AS A LEGISLATURE CALIBRATE. OF
THE SO THAT. THE INVESTMENTS
ARE TRACKING TOGETHER SO THAT
WE- CREATE THE ASSURANCES FOR.
IN OUR RESIDENTS OUR WORKFORCES
CETERA THAT- YOU KNOW WE ARE
GOING TO BE LEAVING PEOPLE
BEHIND HIM WE'VE ACTUALLY WE
ACTUALLY OF. NOT ONLY METRICS
BUT INVESTMENTS THAT ARE. SORT
OF THE EQUIVALENT AYE I KNOW
THEY'RE NOT DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
YOU DON'T. INVEST LIKE THIS IN
IN IN GHG. REDUCTION IN
AUTOMATICALLY HAVE A ONE ONE
RATIO IN TERMS OF JOB
REPLACEMENT BUT I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE AT SOME
POINT NEED TO GET MORE FORMAL
ABOUT TRACKING THAT IS AS A
LEGISLATURE THAT'S MY OPINION.
ON THAT SAID WHO WHAT I ASSUME
YOU HAVE PARTNERS- STAKEHOLDERS
THANK THANKS YOU KNOW AGENCIES
THAT ARE FEEDING INTO- THE DID
THE DATABASE IF YOU WILL- THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT ALL OUT.
IS THAT IS THAT TRUE AND I
DON'T NEED A LIST OF THEM RIGHT
NOW BUT IT'LL BE GREAT ALONG
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU'LL BE SENDING US- THAT MY
COLLEAGUE JUST ASK FOR IF YOU
COULD GIVE. I'M A NEW SENATOR
LIKE ME THAT INFORMATION HAS
SISTER WHO. WHO'S IN THAT WORLD
THAT YOU'RE WORKING WITH AND
GATHERING INFORMATION FROM IT
ON THE MET METRICS OF THE
WORKFORCE TRANSITION. YEAH
THANK YOU SENATOR I WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THAT TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF WE
DO WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS STATE
GOVERNMENT- THAT- IN CHARGE OF
THE CLIMATE WORK- THE PUBLIC%
UTILITIES COMMISSION AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ENERGY
COMMISSION- AND OTHERS- VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM ON
STRATEGIES. FOR INVESTING IN
WORKFORCE BUT ALSO IN MEASURING
IMPACTS- WE WORK WITH ORGANIZED
LABOR AND BUSINESS AND
INDUSTRY- ALSO- THAT'S THE CORE
OF IT ON THE GROUND WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY IS LOOKING FOR
WAYS. TO HELP WORKERS STAY
EMPLOYED IN TRANSITION TO NEW
JOBS SO I'D I'D LOVE TO PROVIDE
YOU A LOT MORE DETAIL ON THAT.
SUMMIT ALSO REFERRED TO A
REPORT WE DID AFTER UC BERKELEY
LABOR CENTER- THAT WAS REQUIRED
AB. NINETY EIGHT- THAT LAYS OUT
THE STRATEGY- YEAH. IN THE
CONTEXT OF A CLIMATE CHANGE IN
TRANSITION. IT'S QUITE A-
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT. IT SOUNDS
LIKE SOMETHING TO BUILD ON THEM
AND THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
FOR THE GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR ALLOW ME TO ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS I DO HAVE ONE. AND
WHAT SUPPORTS CRITERIA FOR
PARDONING PARTNERING WITH-
INDIVIDUALS OR ORGANIZATIONS IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE
SOME OF THESE RESOURCES. AM I
NOTICE THAT- IF NOT ALL OF VERY
LARGE PORTION- JUST SIGNATORY-
ORGANIZATIONS. SO MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE ALL HAVE EVIDENCE THAT
THE IMPACT ON AND THE KOBE
SITUATION HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED. M.
TO TELL YOU WORKERS HOTEL MOTEL
WORKERS RESTAURANT. DISHWASHERS
AND YOU KNOW AGAIN SOME OF THE
LOWEST PAID PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
AND SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
THAT. IS IT A BOARD POLICY TO
ONLY WORK WITH SIGNATORY
COMPANIES AND THE SECOND PART
OF THAT QUESTION IS. I WOULDN'T
IF THAT'S NOT IF THAT IS NOT
THE CASE WOULDN'T IT BEHOOVE
THE BOARD TO WORK WITH PRIVATE
INDUSTRY AS WELL THAT ARE NOT
SIGNATORY COMPANIES SO THAT
PEOPLE THAT WERE MOST AFFECTED
BY THE PANDEMIC. LIKE
RESTAURANT WORKERS HOTEL MOTEL
WORKERS WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE TRANSITION FUNDS
AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATE
THAT'S IT REALLY TERRIFIC
QUESTION- THE CRITERIA OF THE
BOARD IS TO WORK WITH. WHAT WE
CALL HIRED EMPLOYERS- THOSE
EMPLOYERS THAT- THAT PAY A
LIVING WAGE- PROVIDE. A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH BENEFITS-
INVEST IN THEIR WORKERS THROUGH
TRAINING AND UPSKILLING- AND-
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR MILK
MOBILITY INSIDE A COMPANY OR
INSIDE SECTOR- SO DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE SIGNATORY EMPLOYERS AT
ALL- BUT THAT IS A GREAT AREA
WE'RE WE'RE- THE- THE GOAL HERE
IS WE'RE USING- LIMITED DOLLARS
BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
IS SO LARGE- LIMITED DOLLARS
INVESTING THOSE DOLLARS. IN IN
SECTORS EMPLOYERS. THAT OFFER
REALLY GOOD QUALITY JOBS
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO DO OUR
OUR TARGET POPULATIONS ARE
THOSE WHO. ARE LOW INCOME AND
HAVE LOTS OF BAIRSTOW PLAMEN.
SO WE DON'T WANT TO SPEND
LIMITED DOLLARS PUTTING PEOPLE
TO WORK IN- IN HIGH TURNOVER
JOBS WHERE THEY END UP BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM. OUR INTENTION
IS TO MOVE PEOPLE INTO GOOD
QUALITY JOBS THAT HAVE REAL
CAREERS SO WE CAN LIFT
COMMUNITIES AND PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY. SO- SO THAT'S A GREAT
THREE WE HAVE A- BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE THE WORST WORKING ON CALL
TYRA KITCHENS SO IT'S- ENDED.
RESTAURANTS ARE THIS. HELLO
THEM THROUGH THE PANDEMIC FIND
CREATIVE WAYS TO STAY EMPLOYED
TO KEEP WORKERS EMPLOYED. THOSE
ARE NOT SIGNATORY EMPLOYERS BUT
BUT HE'S BEEN VERY GOOD HI
ROADWORK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ANSWERING THAT OF COURSE.
OKAY- I THINK THAT'S IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER RANEY
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST BEFORE YOU
GO ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE THE
NEXT ITEM WE WANT TO ESTABLISH
THE QUORUM. MAP CONSULTANT.
CENTER CORTESE YOUR CENTER OF
HI GOOD. OKAY SO WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE MOVE ON NOW TO
ISSUE TEN. THE QUESTION. RIGHT
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS BECAUSE
I'M NEW TO THE COMMITTEE AND WE
DIDN'T TAKE VOTES LAST TIME AND
ARE WE TAKING VOTES THIS TIME
AND IF WE TAKE FIRST WE TAKEN
LIKE ALL AT ONCE OR DO WE TAKE
THE MATTER EACH ISSUE COULD YOU
JUST GIVE ME A LITTLE
BACKGROUND THANK YOU THANKS SIR
BRIEFLY YEAH SO- ON THE FRONT
OF THE AGENDA- WE USUALLY OF.
WILL WE'LL SHOW IF THERE ARE
ANY VOTE ONLY ITEMS. AS YOU SEE
HERE- ISSUES ONE THROUGH EIGHT.
AND THERE'S NO. ISN'T PATIENTS
MADE ON THOSE ITEMS WE JUST
VOTE ON THEM AND THEN THERE'S
ITEMS PROPOSED FOR DISCUSSION
FOR WHICH- ABODE HAS NOT BEEN-
SO- TODAY WE STARTED WITH ISSUE
NINE. HANDLES WE MOVE FORWARD
ON THAT AT THE END OF THE
MEETING WE WILL VOTE ON ITEMS
ONE THROUGH EIGHT IN ONE
VERSION OR ANOTHER. THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING COMMAND SURE OF
COURSE THANK YOU. OKAY THE
FOLDER DEPARTMENT MAKE A
PRESENTATION ON ISSUE TEN
PLEASE. YES GOOD MORNING
DOWNTOWN PARK WITH THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY. I CUSTOMER THEN THE
AGENDA OF THE LABOR AGENCY IS
CARRYING OUT A MULTI PRONGED
STRATEGY TO CLASS WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS WITH ACTIONABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF KOBE
NINETEEN AND CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SAYS WE ARE
INCORPORATING A MEDIA STRATEGY
WITH A ROBUST COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS IN ORDER TO
REACH COMMUNITIES AND SECTORS
BOTH. FORTUNATELY AND PASSED IT
BY THE PANDEMIC WE'VE ALSO
DEVELOPED MULTIPLE TRAINING
RESOURCES SUCH AS IN DEPTH
WORKSHOPS AND ONLINE COURSES TO
BETTER EQUIP WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS WITH INFORMATION
SCALE AND WE STARTED TO TAKE
ACTION. TO MAKE WORKPLACES
SAFER. SHE GAVE LABOR AGENT AND
OUR DEPART OF INDUSTRY
RELATIONS HAVE COMMITTED NEARLY
TWENTY. OF THE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AUTHORIZED BY
AT THE ONE FIFTEEN ALL TOWARD
COBIT BELATED OUTREACH
EDUCATION AND ENFORCEMENT. I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT TO BE SENT
PUBLIC ANNOUNCEMENTS BEING MADE
AS PART OF THAT BROADER
CAMPAIGN- THE FIRST IS THAT
EARLIER THIS MONTH WE ANNOUNCED
THAT FIFTY FOUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. HAS BEEN FUNDED
TO CONDUCT COVERT RELATED
OUTREACH WITH A FOCUS ON
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN THE
HARDEST HIT BY THE PANDEMIC. IT
ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
CONDUCTING OUTREACH FOR THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS AND REPRESENT
BROAD DIVERSE CITY AND THEIR
REACH. BACK AND LABOR AGENCY
RECENTLY LAUNCHED AN EMPLOYER
PORTAL ON OUR SITE THAT IS A
CENTRALIZED RESOURCE FOR
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYERS TO GET ALL
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED ABOUT
HOW TO FOLLOW LOCAL AND STATE
GUIDANCE. IN ONE CENTRAL HUB.
THESE OUT WE AND TRAINING
ACTIVE. ARE WITH STRATEGIC AND-
BY THE OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE I. R.
HAD. TO CONDUCT TARGETED
ENFORCEMENT TO ADDRESS
VIOLATIONS WHILE UTILIZING THE
ADMISSION OF FUNDING- ALLOCATED
UNDER SB ONE FIFTEEN TO
INCREASE STAFFING CAPACITY AND
UTILIZE TECHNOLOGY TO GAIN
EFFICIENCY AND CLAIMS
PROCESSING AND INVESTIGATION.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS-
ELABORATE FURTHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. I'M ARGUMENT
A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENTS BUT ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU I L. A- DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. I DON'T KNOW THE
L. A- SIMILARLY- THIS EMBRACE
AUTUMN HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS
BUT NO SPECIFIC COMMENTS. OKAY
GREAT- I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- WITH REGARDS TO THE
FUNDS THAT WE'RE GOING TO- I
GUESS THAT WORKERS FOR
WORKPLACE IS MY UNDERSTANDING
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE FOR
WORKPLACE EDUCATION- HOW HOW
WERE THE FUNDS USE CAN YOU GIVE
ME EXAMPLES OF HOW THAT. WAS
USED TO HELP THE WORKERS AND
THE WORKPLACES CARRY OUT HEALTH
PROTOCOLS. YES WORKERS ARE
RECEIVING EDUCATION THROUGH
BOTH THE CBO OUTREACH EFFORTS
AS WELL AS SOME TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING CARRIED
OUT BY OUR PARTNERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. SO ON
THE FIRST POINT DEVIDOS- WHAT
THE FIFTY FOUR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WE ARE TRYING. ARE BEING
TRAINED- WITH WORKPLACE RIGHT
INFORMATION ON HOW TO NAVIGATE
DIFFERENT STATE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AND- THAT INFORMATION
IS REALLY WHAT THEY WILL USE TO
ENGAGE ON A DEEPER HIGH LEVEL-
OUTREACH OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE
ORGANIZATION WITHOUT WITHOUT
COMMUNITIES AND BY THAT I MEAN.
WE'RE GOING BEYOND- ONE WAY
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS WIRING OR-
COUNTY THING AND WE'RE REALLY
ASKING THE ORGANIZATION TO
CONDUCT WORKSHOPS PRESENTATIONS
AND HAVE ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATIONS IN ORDER TO
REALLY ASK THAT. FOLKS TO
CONNECT TO THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED- FIND THE MORE
TRAINING RELATED- PROGRAMS WE
ARE PARTNERING WITH- UC
BERKELEY UC DAVIS AND UCLA AND
THEIR RESPECTIVE WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY BANNER. WHO
HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
PROVIDING COMMUNITY TRAINING TO
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS SOMETIMES
IN VERY THANK INDUSTRY ABOUT
HOW TO ADOPT AND COOL HMO THAT
PRACTICES AROUND BURKE THINK
HELPING EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS
OTHER RELATED CO BAD BITE. SUCH
A TAPE THAT CLEAN- AND- ANTI
RETALIATION UNDERSTANDING THAT
ALL OF THESE RIGHT I NEED TO.
BE COMPLIMENTING EACH OTHER IN
ORDER TO REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
CODE. AND MARK STONE. DID YOU-
IN ADVANCE. NO OR TARA CERTAIN
INTO ARE THAT YOU THOUGHT MIGHT
NEED IT MORE. OR WAS IT THROUGH
THE COME BAY DRUG. THAT THEY DO
AND THEN LATER TOLD YOU WHAT
THEY WERE DOING. OF WHAT KIND
OF. PLANNING OR MAPPING WAS
DONE ON ON IN THAT SENSE. YES
WE DID CONTROLLED WHERE- DIR
INDICATED THAT WE HAVE ON
ENFORCEMENT OF VIOLATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO COMPLAINTS
THAT WE FOURTEEN ESTABLISH WHAT
ARE THOSE HIGHER RISK INDUSTRY-
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT DATA IS
GENERALLY ALIGNED WITH- THAT
THE NEW TAG LINE IN TERMS OF
THE ESSENTIAL INDUSTRY FOR
FRONT LINE WORKERS THANK YOU
CAN YOU TO- TO- ST TO BE. TO GO
TO WORK- AND BE EXPOSED- TO
EACH OTHER AND THE PUBLIC SO-
WE DID IDENTIFY TARGET INDUSTRY-
AND THEN WE IDENTIFIED
ORGANIZATION HAD REACHED. INTO
THOSE INDUSTRIES- AND THOUGH
THOSE INDUSTRIES ARE- I CAN
LIST THEM. OUT- THEY ARE-
JANITORIAL OF THE INCLUDES-
HOUSEKEEPING- DIFFERENT TACK OF
WHICH FOOD PROCTOR R. AS AS
PACKING I RESTAURANT AND THEN
WE HAVE MANY FACTS WITH THE
OBJECTIVE GARMENT IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA- AND THEN OF
COURSE AFTER CULTURE- FARM
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS ADDS
ACTORS- AND- WAREHOUSE AND
LOGISTICS. OKAY THANK YOU- AND
JUST ONE MORE- ISSUE HERE I
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
RECEIVE SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
ENFORCEMENT OF PROTECTIONS TO
ASSIST HOSPITALITY WORKERS AND
RETURNING TO WORK- THIS IS OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN TO ME
BECAUSE WOMEN MAKE UP MORE THAN
HALF OF THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY- AND THAT THEY'VE BEEN
HIT THE HARDEST BY WOMEN ARE
STRUGGLING MORE. THAN MEN WE
ALL REMEMBER DECEMBER'S REPORT
AND IT SHOWED A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND JOBS LOST ALL WERE
HELD BY WOMEN IN TOTAL WOMEN
LOST A HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND JOBS SO- THE PANDEMIC-
RELATED JOB LOSSES WERE AMONGST
HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS WOMEN OF
COLOR OVER FIFTY- AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE THE LOWEST STATISTICAL
POSSIBILITY OF EVEN BEING
INTERVIEWED FOR A NEW JOB SO
GETTING BACK TO THE JOB IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THEIR
LIVELIHOOD- JOBLESS WOMEN ARE
18% LESS LIKELY TO FIND NEW
WORK AT AGE FIFTY TO SIXTY ONE-
AND AS YOU GET OLDER OLDER I
LIKE SIXTY TWO AN OLDER. THERE
50% LESS LIKELY TO BE REHIRED-
SO THIS IS A THIS PARTICULAR
OUR AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
ENFORCEMENT OF- THEIR RIGHT TO
RETURN TO THEIR JOBS- IS OF
AGAIN PARTICULAR. IMPORTANCE TO
ME- I HOPE DIDN'T. WILL ENGAGE
WITH US ON THIS AND LET US KNOW
IF THE RECALL RIGHTS PROPOSAL
OUR RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
THE BEETLE OF- AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN- WITH THAT I IF YOU
HAVE ANY RESPONSE TO. THE
SPECIFICALLY THE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A WAS SET ASIDE FOR-
RETURNING TO WORK FOR THOSE
WORKERS. YES A FIFTY DOLLARS
HAS BEEN UTILIZED FOR STRATEGIC
ENFORCEMENT INCREASED CAPACITY
CLOSURE. TWO INCLUDE
HOSPITALITY WORKERS AS WELL AS
OTHER HIGH RISK INDUSTRIES- AND
WE'VE TAKEN A VERY HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO- ENHANCED
ENFORCEMENT- STILL WE ALSO FEED
OUTREACH WORK AS PART OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS IN OUR
EXPERIENCE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
AFFECTED OUTREACH IT WILL
HAMPER THE ABILITY OF OUR STATE
STAFF TO DEAL EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT. OF THE FRONTLINE
OF IMPORTANCE AS OUTREACH AND
FILLS WE NEED TO HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE- DEATH
YOU HAVE REACHED IN Q.
HOSPITALITY WORKERS AND THEY
WILL ALSO BE WORKING HAND IN
HAND WITH OUR DEPARTMENT STAFF
YOU IDENTIFY CHIEF. AND
REFERRED FINANCIAL AYE HIGH
IMPACT CASES TO OUR DEPARTMENT
AND DIVISION- AND THEN ON THAT
ENFORCEMENT- WE NOT ONLY ARE WE
ARE INVESTIGATING AND FINDING
VIOLATIONS IN THE INDUSTRY BUT
WE ARE ALSO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH EMPLOYERS
TO PROMOTE COMPLIANCE- AND YOU
KNOW. CALSHOT DIVISION DOES
HAVE A CONSULTATION BRANCH THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO CONSULT-
WITHOUT RISK OF- ENFORCEMENT OF
THE WALL BETWEEN THE
COMPLICATION BRANCH AND THAT
ENFORCEMENT. UNIT I FEEL THAT
EMPLOYERS CAN GET HELP WITH A
COMPLIANCE AND THAT LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE HAS ALSO
LAUNCHED AND EARLY ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAMS- TARGETING BUSINESSES
SO THAT IT PROVIDES EARLY
INTERVENTION- INTO- PREVENT
FURTHER VIOLATIONS SO WE COUPLE
OUTREACH WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
AND THEN OF COURSE THERE'S
LITTLE PLASTIC WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT ALSO-
AND PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
SUPPORT TEST INDUSTRY- AND THIS
IS A BROADER SPECTRUM OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO- HE USED TO
THE COURT HI THE TALLY IN THE-
ALONG. WITH OTHER HIGH RISK AND-
OKAY THANK YOU I WOULD TO GET
MORE IN OF THAT- ENTER OF THIS
AMOUNT THAT WENT DODD TO THEM
FOR OF ASSIST AUSTIN WERE TO
GET JOB BACK THANK YOU MUCH
SENATORS SAY NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MEDICARE SO YOUR QUESTION MISS
PARKER SO I I'VE QUESTION
AROUND THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN SPECIFICALLY. THAT THE
TEN MILLION DOLLAR PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN CONDUCTED
THROUGH AN AGENCY SO THAT'S
ABOUT 40% OF THE TOTAL
EXPENDITURE. HOW DID YOU
DETERMINE THAT ALLOCATION- AND-
YOU KNOW WHY THAT AMOUNT
ESPECIALLY AGAINST OTHER
EFFORTS LIKE COMMUNICATION. AND
HOW DO YOU MEASURE SUCCESS OF A
PUBLIC. ANNOUNCEMENT CAMPAIGN
LIKE HAT ESPECIALLY THE VERY.
KIND OF COWDED NOISY MEDIA
MARKET IS THAT IS THAT THE BEST
RETURN ON THAT INVESTMENT. YES
SO THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES AND TACTICS BEING
DEPLOYED UNDER THAT MEDIA
CAMPAIGN- SO THEY DO INCLUDE A
TRADITIONAL MEDIA THINGS LIKE
RADIO ADS OUT DOOR ADS- IN
DIGITAL- ADD- BUT THEY ALSO.
PROVIDE OR THE ABILITY TO
PROMOTE LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND
HAVE MORE ROBUST INFORMATION
AND- MANY MORE LANGUAGES SO
THAT CONTRACT ALLOWS THAT Q.
NOT JUST PUT OUT ADS IN THE
MEDIA MARKET BUT CREATE
OUTREACH MATERIALS. AND MORE
LANGUAGE SO WE HAVE CURRENTLY A
LIST OF TWENTY SEVEN LANGUAGES
THANKS WE WANT TO PRODUCE OUT
WE CAN CARRY OUT THE AND- AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE- INFORMATION
YOU CAN GET YOUR LANGUAGE AND-
WE'RE DEVELOPING INFORMATION
AND MOM. COPY THAT WERE REALLY
TRYING TO BE EXPENSIVE AND
EXPANSIVE AND HOW WE ARE
REACHING A PUBLIC THROUGH THOSE
PUBLIC AWARENESS DOLLARS I'M
STILL JUST MY FIRST POINT IS TO
CLARIFY THAT. WHILE THERE ISN'T
A BUSINESS ON PAID MEDIA- THAT
WORK ALSO COMPASSES OUTREACH
AND THAT IT CREATED ALLOWS US
TO CREATE MORE ROBUST
INFORMATION I THANK YOU THE-
THE OTHER PARTNERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS CAN ACCESS. IN
THAT IN THAT APPROPRIATE
LANGUAGE- IN TERMS OF MEASURING
SUCCESS CERTAINLY THERE IS- IS
THAT TRADITIONAL COMMUNICATIONS
ON THAT TRICKS THAT WE ARE
TRACKING IN TERMS OF REACH. BUT
WE ALSO ANECDOTALLY ARE ALREADY
OBSERVING. AN IMPACT TO
ENFORCEMENT AND THAT WE ARE WE
THINKING MARK PHONE CALLS
WORKING MORE WEB TRAFFIC
BECAUSE THE AD YOU TRIED. THE
PUBLIC TO OUR PRIMARY RESOURCES.
ON OUR WEBSITE AND SO WE ARE
SEEING THAT- IN THAT WORK THE
P. PAY MEDIA IS WORKING. OUT
MORE WE'VE ALSO BEEN RESEARCH
THROUGH- THROUGH THAT CAN. AND
TO THE CONTRACT- WITH THAT
MEDIA VENDOR AT THE RESEARCH
HAS- INCLUDE FOCUSED GROUPS I
WITH IMPACTED. ON A SECTOR AND
THE ALSO CONDUCTED INTERVIEWS
WITH. INCLUDING AN- AND DO THAT
WE MAY BEEN ABLE TO H WHAT
IS IT WHERE ARE THE FOR GAP AND
WATER THAT BACK WAYS GET THE
MESSAGE OUT- SO FOR A- THE-
ESTABLISH THROUGH THE RESEARCH
THERE IS QUITE. A LOT OF
CONFUSION ABOUT WHICH
DEPARTMENT WHICH DIVISION
PROVIDES WHICH SERVICES AND HOW
WORKERS CAN NAVIGATE HOW
EMPLOYER CAN NAVIGATE- ALL OF
THAT THEY ARE YET EIGHT
PROGRAMS AND SO THESE ARE ALL
LEARNING THAT WE ARE APPLYING-
AND THAT THAT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WILD- IT IS ABOUT EQUAL
TO THE AMOUNT. THAT WERE
INVESTED. TO THE CBO OUTREACH
ACTIVITY IT REALLY DOES UNDER
GUARD- DATE ENFORCEMENT AS WELL
AS THE OUTREACH WORK BECAUSE
THREE OUT RESEARCH AND THROUGH
THAT CAN TRANSLATION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF COLLATERAL WERE
ABLE TO MAKE ALL. THE
INFORMATION MORE ACCESSIBLE.
IT'S JUST I GUESS WHAT I'M HERE
IS THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS.
MAYBE SOME GOING OFF STAFF
ANALYSIS SO THAT THAT'S NOT
STRICTLY SPEAKING- HELLO OPEN
WITH ME OF MONEY PER SE IT'S
JUST A BUNCH OF OTHER AREAS.
AND SO I DON'T SHE BE GREAT.
FOR A SOME DE SO WE COULD SEE.
HOW THAT BREAKS DOWN IN AND HOW
IT RELATES TO OTHER- IF ONLY
FOR A FEW REF BUT BUT THANK YOU
FOR THE INFORMATION. I THINK
THIS IS. GOING TO GROW. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
FEW I USE IN THE B. PARK THAT
YOU ARE CONTACTED WITH A FIFTY
FOUR ORGANIZATIONS OR INDUSTRY
FOR ORGANIZATIONS WAS ONE OF
THOSE OR WERE TWO OF THOSE A
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION OR THE CALIFORNIA-
HOSPITALITY IN HOTEL AND
LODGING ASSOCIATION. DO YOU
RECALL. I DON'T BELIEVE SO WE
DO HAVE- YOUR SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE LOS
ANGELES CHAMBER OF COMERCE
ANNUAL WORKFORCE PARTNERSHIP
BY- THOSE TWO THAT YOU NAMED-
pFUNDING. PROGRAM THANK YOU AND
IF I COULD GET A LIST OF THAT
SENT TO MY OFFICE THE
ORGANIZATIONS WHICH SHE
CONTRACTED WITH I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT IT SEEMS LIKE TO
ME AGAIN GOING BACK TO THE MOST
AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE OF
THE GOVERNOR SHUT DOWN WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY. OF HOTEL WORKERS
WHICH THE WOMAN SAID M. AND
ADEQUATELY- ENERGY SHE FOCUSED
ON THE FACT THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THEM ARE WOMEN WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE. AND SERVICE
WORKERS AS FAR AS HOSPITALITY
IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
THOSE TWO INDUSTRIES ALONG WITH
SOLANO OUR SALON STYLIST WERE
THE MOST AFFECTED- INDUSTRIES
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION OR THE HOSPITALITY
WORKERS THAT DO SERVERS. THE-
HOTEL- AND- IN. IS AS WORKERS
IN THE HOTEL INDUSTRY. INSIDERS
MY CURIOSITY IS THAT IF YOU
HAVE AN ORGANIZATION PER SE
LIKE FINAL CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION THAT
HAS. BEEN A ONE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS
RESTAURANTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE OVER TO
FOREMOST TWO MILLION EMPLOYEES-
DEBBIE IS PRETTY EFFECTIVE WAY
TO REACH THOSE EMPLOYEES TO
TEACH THEM ABOUT- SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHY. I'M CURIOUS WHY
AND HOW. YOU WOULD PICK THE
ORGANIZATIONS IN WHICH YOU
PARTNERED WITH- WIND- IN A MUCH.
ADVOCATING COME SENSE RIGHT
THESE PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE THAT WERE
AFFECTED BY THAT THAT GOVERNOR
SHUT DOWN- SO I AM CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT AND- AND I AM I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HALF OF WHAT
OF THE FIFTY FOUR I BELIEVE FOR
A FIFTY. FIFTY FOUR AT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU
PARTNERED WITH SO I'D LIKE THAT
LIST IN IN- I'D LIKE AN
EXPLANATION OF WHY YOU WOULDN'T
PARTNER THE SENATE HAD ACCESS
TO OVER TWO MILLION RESTAURANT
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE AFFECTED BY
THE GOVERNOR SAID DOWN. SO THAT
THEY COULD BE ADEQUATELY-
INFORMED ME I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU PAID A CONSULTANT TO DO
YOUR DIGITAL MEDIA CAMPAIGN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU PAID- I
KNOW THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IS ALLOCATED. BUT I THINK A
SIMPLE EMAIL- OUT TO ONE OF THE
FROM ONE OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
TO LET EMPLOYEES KNOW- THE
BENEFITS OF WHAT YOU WERE
ALLOWING THEM TO DO AN
EMPLOYER'S. AT THE SMALL BIT
RESTAURANTS THAT HAVE- BEEN
DRASTICALLY AFFECTED BY THE
SHUTDOWN WOULD BE BENEFICIAL.
AND THAT AND A GREAT WAY TO
REACH I'M A MULTITUDE OF PEOPLE
THAT WERE TRYING TO REACH. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR WE WILL
PROVIDE THAT LIST IT IS HOSTED
PUBLICLY- THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED AND- I DO
WANT TO- EIGHT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO PARTNERING WITH GARY YES
CLEAR AN INDUSTRY. ORGANIZATION
AND WE HAVE DONE SO SOMETIMES-
THE DAY THEY ME SO WHEN YOU
TAKE A STEP BACK STILL WORKING
INDICATIONS THAT ARE FUNDED
OUR- KINI BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT. ARE IN IT EXPECTED TO GO
OUT INTO THE FIELD AND REACH
THE HARD TO REACH COMMUNITIES-
IN THE MOST HARDEST HIT
FACTORED THAT BEING SAID WE ARE
ALSO ENGAGED IN PARTNERING WITH
EMPLOYERS TO GET INFORMATION
AND- ASK ABOUT THE EMPLOYER
PORTAL THAT WE'VE CREATED OUT
TO EMPLOYERS. YEAH WE'VE MATT
WHERE OSHER WHY EMPLOYER ARE.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO TO
DEVELOP. AND GROW PARTNERSHIPS
WITH OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO DO
THINGS LIKE EMAIL BLAST WEAPON.
AFTER WE- TRAININGS AND
PRESENTATIONS TO THEIR MEMBERS
WHICH DO INCLUDE EMPLOYERS AND
MANY OF OUR UC'S TRAINING
WORKSHOP THAT WE'RE FINDING ARE
ALSO TARGETED TO EMPLOYERS AND
ARE BEING PROMOTED. IN ACTIVE
PARTNERSHIP WITH EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATIONS SO WE CERTAINLY
DO HAVE MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WE ENGAGE WITH
ORGANISATIONS- ARE STATE WIDE
INDUSTRY LEADERS AND. WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU MEASURE THANK
YOU FOR. OKAY THANK YOU MUCH-
LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE. BUT
TWELVE NUMBER ELEVEN. WE SHOULD
ELEVENTH OF DILLON SKIP OVER
THAT- OKAY- A WILL BE ON THE
PRESENT PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CAN RAINY HERE- SORRY FOR
SHOWING UP AGAIN. VERY VERY
QUICKLY- WALK THROUGH THE
PROPOSAL- AND- TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS IS
THE SAME PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR
MAY LAST YEAR- THE PROPOSAL IS
TO CONSOLIDATE FOR WORKFORCE
ENTITIES BETTER WITHIN THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT- INTO ONE SINGLE
WORKFORCE- DEPARTMENT UNDER
COMMON LEADERSHIP WITH COMMON
GOALS- INCOME STRATEGIES- SO
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. ANY
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL ARE
BOTH WITHIN TE LABOR AGENCY
THEY WOULD COME TOGETHER WHOLE
CLOTH. THE DIVISION DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS WHICH
IT WOULD BE PULLED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND THE WORK FOR
SERVICES BRANCH EDT WOULD BE
PULLED INTO THE NEW DEPARTMENT
AS WELL. IT'S A TWO STEP
PROCESS. A STATUTORY CHANGES
THIS YEAR THAT'S WHAT'S BEFORE-
YOU- AND THAT IS THAT
CONSOLIDATING THIS STATUTORY
LANGUAGE RELATED TO THIS FOR
ENTITIES INTO A NEW DIVISION
SIX OF THE LABOR CODE. MY
COLLEAGUE MICHAEL CABELL WHOSE
ON- CAN WALK YOU THROUGH ANY
DETAILS ON THAT- THAT YOU NEED
TO WALK THROUGH- BUDGET CHANGES
WOULD BE NEXT YEAR. SO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT WILL SUBMIT A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE REQUESTING TO MOVE
OTHER POSITIONS- FROM. THE
DEPARTMENTS AFFECTED- THAT WERE
PULLING- FROM- AND AGAIN THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL IN
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. THEY BECOME
WHOLE CLOTH- SO- IT'S GOING TO
TAKE US. A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME IN THIS IS GOOD BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO BE VERY DELIBERATE
ABOUT THIS- FOR STANDING UP THE
NEW DEPARTMENT IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY IN FACT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT- AT
FOUR YEAR- TO THIS POINT. AND
WILL BE WORKING ON IT FOR
ANOTHER YEAR- JUST A COUPLE OF
REASONS WHY THIS CONSOLIDATION
IS IMPORTANT. FIRST FOUR SHOULD
FOLLOW FOR. THE WORKFORCE
SERVICES BRANCH. INSIDE ET DE
IS A WORK FORCE FUNCTION WITHIN
A DEPARTMENT WHOSE PRIMARY
FOCUS IS ON BENEFITS AND
TAXATION INCLUDING UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS- THE DIVISION
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS. IS A
WORK FORCE FUNCTION. THAT IS
WITHIN A DEPARTMENT WHOSE
PRIMRY FOCUS IS LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THE WAY WE DESIGNED
THIS. IS ABOUT WHAT PAYING A
LOT OF ATTENTION TO FORM
FOLLOWING FUNCTION. THE
CONSOLIDATED WORKFORCE
DEPARTMENT WILL FOCUS ON
WORKFORCE. WHICH IS CRITICAL
NOW AS WE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
HELPING WORKERS TRANSITION AND
DIFFICULT TIMES. GET ACCESS TO
GOOD QUALITY JOBS SO THE NEW
DEPARTMENTS FOCUSED ON INDUSTRY
PARTNERSHIPS AND REGIONAL
TALENT DEVELOPMENT. PATHWAYS TO
QUALITY JOBS. EQUITY IN INCOME
ABILITY AS WE TALKED ABOUT FOR
PEOPLE WHO MOST NEED GOOD JOBS
HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY THIS
CRISIS. AND OF COURSE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- THE SECOND REASON.
FOR THE SYSTEM ALIGNMENT. IS
ACHIEVE A GREATER SCALE AND
IMPACT FOR CURRENT OUR CURRENT
INVESTMENTS. WORKFORCE PROGRAM
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED LOCALLY
THERE UP THERE NOT DELIVERED
FROM SACRAMENTO. BEAT THEIR
DELIVERED WHERE- WHERE PEOPLE
NEED SERVICES- AND THEY'RE
SCATTERED ACROSS MULTIPLE
AGENCIES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITH DIFFERENT MISSIONS
DIFFERENT PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS
DIFFERENT SERVICE CULTURES.
THAT MAKES IT REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR COMPANIES AND FOR WORKERS
TO NAVIGATE. IT'S JUST TOO
COMPLEX IS TOO MUCH OF
PATCHWORK. THAT GETS IN THE WAY
OF GREATER IMPACT FROM- FROM
OUR INVESTMENTS- WE DON'T THINK
THE FIX CAN ONLY HAPPEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL I SAY THAT BECAUSE
WE PUSHED. OUT FOR A LONG TIME.
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ALIGN THEIR
SERVICES. AND THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BECAUSE AGAIN THAT'S THE POINT
OF SERVICE DELIVERY. BUT WE
CREATE THE DYSFUNCTION. IN
SACRAMENTO TO A LARGE EXTENT-
SO WE NEED TO WALK THE TALK WE
NEED TO DO THE ALIGNMENT IN
SACRAMENTO. BUT THE FEDS NEED
TO DO THE ALIGNMENT- SO THAT
WHEN IT GETS DOWN TO LOCAL
AGENCIES. THOSE SERVICES ARE
BETTER ALIGNED TO PEOPLE CAN
NAVIGATE THOSE AND GET ACCESS
TO THE SERVICES NEED AND SO
COMPANIES CAN GET ACCESS TO THE
WORKERS THAT THEY NEED TO HIRE-
THIS CONSOLIDATION IS A STEP. I
BIG STEP TOWARD ALIGNING
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS UNDER THE
SAME LEADERSHIP I ENVISIONED
THROUGH A SINGLE WORKFORCE.
THAT. ENTITY- I THINK THAT.
WELL I KNOW BECAUSE WE GOT A
LETTER FROM BOTH LABOR BUSINESS
THAT THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THIS PARTICULAR ASPECT OF
NAVIGABILITY FOR WORKERS AND
FOR COMPANIES- BUSINESSES AND-
WORKER REPRESENTATIVES AROUND
THE STATE HAVE HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED BY THE DIFFICULTY OF
ACCESSING SERVICES I MEAN IT'S
NOT THAT THE INVESTMENT IS TOO
SMALL ISSUE IT IT MAY BE- BUT
IT'S JUST NOT A LINES WELL
ENOUGH SO WE RECEIVE LETTERS
FROM THAT CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THAT CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION YOU COMMITTEE HAS-
AND THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND ALOT OF OTHER
ENTITIES TWELVE OR THIRTEEN
TOTAL- THAT SAY THEY SHOULD
HAPPEN THIS DEBATE SUPPORT THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT SO I THINK. WHEN
YOU HAVE LABOR- AND IN BUSINESS
TOGETHER ON THE SAME PAGE OR
SOMETHING OR SOMETHING
CERTAINLY RIGHT GOING ON- THE
WORK IS NOT DONE WITH THIS
THERE STILL ARE THIRTY
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS IN
SACRAMENTO THEY'RE ADMINISTERED
TO THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND SEVEN AGENCIES
SO THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM FOR
MISALIGNMENT AND FRAGMENTATION
THAT CONSUMES PRECIOUS TIME.
THAT COMPANIES DON'T HAVE AN
CERTAINLY JOB SEEKERS DON'T
HAVE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TIME
RESOURCES TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PATCHWORK OF
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE NEED TO FIX
THAT- SO THEY SAY THIS
CONSOLIDATION WITHIN THE LABOR
AGENCY ONLY IS. SIGNIFICANT FOR
STEP IT'S GOOD GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER RAINY- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. YES MARC JIMENEZ
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
PURPOSE OF THIS REORGANIZATION
IS TO MAKE EFFICIENCIES IN THE
STATE'S FRAGMENTED WORK FOR
SYSTEMS ON TO IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY ON WHICH IS A CRITICAL
STRATEGY AS WE WORK TOWARDS THE
STATE'S OUT QUICK ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND I GETTING PEOPLE
INTO GOOD QUALITY. JOBS I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS THE
L.A. O. OFFICE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON IT. DONNA WITH-
LET'S ANALYSTS OFFICE WE'VE
PRODUCED A SHORT ANALYSIS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO CREATE THE NEW DEPARTMENT OF
BETTER JOBS AND HIGHER WAGES
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO IT'S GOING TO
BRING UP THREE POINTS FROM THE
ANALYSIS. ON THE FIRST IS THAT
THE FUNCTIONS PROPOSED TO BE
PERFORMED BY THE NEW DEPARTMENT
SEEM TO US. TO BE VERY SIMILAR
TO THE COORDINATING ROLE THAT
LABOR AGENCY ITSELF HAS
HISTORICALLY PLAYED. INTO THE
QUESTION- ALONG THIS LINE FOR
OUR OFFICES REALLY WHAT'S
PREVENTING ON THESE FUNCTIONS
AND THESE PROGRAMS FROM. MORE
COORDINATED. WITH A SINGLE
VISION AS AS MISTER READY
MENTIONED- CURRENTLY SO WHAT
ARE THE BARRIERS THEIR AGENCY
AND IN AND THE ADMINISTRATION
UP TO THIS POINT HASN'T CLEARLY
ARTICULATED WHY. LABOR AGENCY
ISN'T ABLE TO COORDINATE THESE
FUNCTIONS AS IT HAPPENED THE
PAST THE SECOND ISSUE THAT
THERE WE RAISING THE ANALYSIS-
IS IT IS IT IS NOT CLEAR OUR
OFFICE WHAT SPECIFIC PROBLEM IS
INTENDED TO BE SOLVED BY
CREATING A NEW DEPARTMENT OF
BETTER JOBS AND HIGHER WGES-
WITHOUT A CLEAR PROBLEM
STATEMENT. A DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS SUB
COMMITTEE TO SORT OF JUDGE THE
PROPOSAL AND ALSO DIFFICULT IN
THE FUTURE DECEPTICON ABILITY
AND TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
MEETING ITS OBJECTIVES. ON THE
THIRD ISSUE WE RAISING ANALYSIS
AND ONE THAT'S MOST IMPORTANT-
IN OUR REVIEW- I'VE GIVEN THE
PANDEMIC IS THAT THE PROPOSED
NEW DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBSAND HIGHER WAGES WOULD SHIFT
ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED STAFF.
FROM THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO THE NEW
DEPARTMENT AND THE LEAST OFF AS
MISTER RANEY MENTIONED WORKING
WORK FOR SERVICES AND NOT
DIRECTLY WITH THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM- WE WORRY.
THAT LEADERSHIP BOTH AT THE
LABOR AGENCY AND AT THE EDT
WOULD SPEND CONSIDERABLE FOCUS
AND ATTENTION. ON WHAT IS A
CHALLENGING REORGANIZATION
PROCESS OBJECTS DESCRIBE FROM
STATE'S CALL. INTEREST AND- IT
WILL THE BACK OF YOUR CLAY TO
PROCESS- AND- IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING OUR FRAUDULENT CLAIM
ACTIVITY HAVE YOU DEEPER IN
THIS TIME AS A MOVING FORWARD
AT THIS POINT- SEEMS TO POSE A
SERIOUS REST RISK AND ARGUE TO
THE STATE'S THE STATE'S CLEAR
EFFORTS NOW- WITH YOU I AT THE
ET- THAT ARE ONGOING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
RANEY COULD YOU RESPOND TO
THOSE. QUESTIONS BY THE L. A.
O. OF COORDINATION WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM AND- THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON EDT. I MEAN POTENTIAL
IMPACT ACTUALLY ON THE CLAIMS
THE MEN AND WOMEN FILE CLAIMS
AND ADD. SURE I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AND I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES A CHANCE ALAMOS
ANALYSIS- V. THERE ARE THREE
THINGS THAT THAT THAT MISTER
ALMA BROUGHT UP NUMBER ONE ISI
THINK A STRUCTURAL. ISSUE THAT
I WANT TO. RESPOND TO THE OTHER
IS THE PROBLEM TO SOLVE- AND I
CAN I CAN REITERATE THAT ONE-
AND THAT POTENTIAL DISRUPTION
TO. EDIE'S WORK AROUND
BENEFITS- THE STRUCTURAL ONE
IS. UP WHICH WE HAVE DONE A
GREAT DEAL OF ALIGNMENT AMONG
THESE DEPARTMENTS AND SERVICES
OVER OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS- VERY INTENTIONAL ABOUT
IT OVER THE LAST YEARS WE
WORKED AT AS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON. DEVELOPING THE NEW
DEPARTMENT- HOWEVER- THE REAL
pWOULD BE SOLD BY ONE SINGLE
DEPARTMENT AND THOSE ARE.
MULTIPLE EIGHT DEPARTMENTS OR
ENTITIES THAT DO THEIR OWN
CONTRACTING- MULTIPLE ENTITIES
TO HAVE THEIR OWN LEGAL I DO
LEGAL ANALYSIS AND- MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS DO PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT. SO AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL A SINGLE WORKFORCE
ENTITY. LIKE A LOCAL WORK FOR
SUPPORT FOR EXAMPLE COULD HAVE
GRANTS FROM THE STATE WORKFORCE
BOARDS HIRING TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP COULD HAVE ANY G.
P. GRANT- COULD BE. GETTING
FUNDING OR REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT ARE OVERSEEN BY
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. AND MAY BE RUNNING
AN APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM ALL
AT THE SAME TIME AND THEY HAVE
TO DEAL WITH DIFFERENT
CONTRACTING ENTITIES DIFFERENT
LEGAL INTERPRETATIONS DIFFERENT
CRIED. PROGRAM MANAGEMENT- THAT
HAVE DIFFERENT SERVICE DELIVERY
CULTURES. IT'S SPECTRUM AND IT
IS. TAKING AWAY. OUR VALUABLE
RESOURCES TO THOSE ENTITIES
THAT HAVE TO FOCUS ALL THE BACK
ON ADMINISTRATION INSTEAD OF
PROVIDING SERVICES. TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM IN THE
BUSINESSES WHO NEED THEIR
SERVICES- SO THE STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGE NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND THAT'S BEYOND. THE GOOD
WORK I THINK WE'VE DONE- IN
INTO LINING. UP OR OR WORK
ACROSS THESE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES. THE SECOND ONE IS A
PROBLEM TO SOLVE AND I. I
BELIEVE THAT. WELL I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT REALLY THE INTENT
HERE. IS TO MAKE THIS SYSTEM OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
ANYBODY ANY BUSINESS WHO'S
TRYING TO GET GET SERVICES. OUT
FROM THE WORK FORCE SYSTEM. ANY
JOB SEEKERS TRYING TO FIND
ACCESS TO SERVICES. WILL SAY
THIS THAT IT'S COMPLEX IT'S A
PATCHWORK IN IS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT AND TO NAVIGATE- SO
THE INTENTION. HERE THAT'S THE
PROBLEM WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE IN
THE THIS IS MOVING THE OF
SOLVING PROMISED THE IT'S NOT-
THAT SILVER BOW. BUT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY- TO GET THEIR- WHERE
THE SERVICES ARE ARE I'M WE'RE
MAXIMIZING THE IMPACT WITH
THESE INVESTMENTS OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S MAKING- AND THEN
DISRUPTION WITH IMMEDIATE.
TAKING THE WORK FOR SERVICES
WORK- AND MOVING INTO A
DEPARTMENT WHOSE SOLE FOCUS. IS
WORKFORCE AWAY FROM A
DEPARTMENT THAT WHERE THE
LEADERSHIP IS CONSUMED AND
SHOULD BE CONCERNED- AND IS AND
IS WORKING VERY VERY HARD. TO
IMPROVE THE DELIVERY OF
BENEFITS TO PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN A CRISIS. IT
IS ABSOLUTELY THERIGHT MOVE-
IMMEDIATE WILL ON GOING FOCUS
ON BENEFITS AND TAXATION. AND
THE WORK FORCE PIECE IS GOING
TO GET THE FOCUS IT DESERVES
AND IT NEEDS ESPECIALLY IN A
CRISIS BY BEING IN A DEPARTMENT
THAT IS FOCUSED ON WORKFORCE. I
HOPE BY AT RESPONDED TO THE TO
THE THREE POINTS. THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS IS- HOW DO YOU SEE
THAT THE CONSOLIDATION UP COULD
EXPAND JOB TRAINING AND
APPRENTICESHIPS ESPECIALLY FOR
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
COMMUNITIES- OF. CAN THIS
CONSOLIDATION. THANK GOD ON
MORE ASSERTIVELY AND YOU KNOW
GET GREATER RESULTS. OR IS THAT
JUST SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
GOING TO BE A PUNCHED. YEAH I
THINK THANK YOU SENATOR IS A
GREAT QUESTION- THE NEW
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO BE
BUILT- ROUNDED THE CORE
PRINCIPLES OF HIGH ROAD THAT I
TALKED ABOUT A BIT EARLIER-
INDUSTRY GAUGE WHEN A FOCUS
THAT SO ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
WORKFORCE ENTITIES ARE
CURRENTLY DOING INDUSTRY
ENGAGEMENT SEPARATELY SO
BRINGING THAT TOGETHER AROUND
THIS HYBRID CONCEPT. A DEEP
INDUSTRY ENGAGEMENT- SO IT'S
KIND OF A ALIGNMENT OF THOSE
EFFORTS BUT WITHIN THE MISSION
STRATEGIES OF HIGH ROAD
FOCUSING ON SECTORS. IN
REGIONS- SECTORS ARE DRIVING
EMPLOYMENT AND CREATING
PATHWAYS TO THOSE GOOD QUALITY
JOBS FOR PEOPLE WHO MOST NEED
THEM- AND THEN SECONDLY- JOB
SEEKER SERVICES ALIGNING THOSE
AT THE STATE LEVEL GETS OF IT
THAT'S THE SUPPLY THE SERVICES
ARE NAVIGABLE OF MAKING THAT
HAPPEN AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THE CONNECTING PROGRAMS.
PATHWAYS TO THOSE GOOD JOBS-
AND THEN THE THIRD PIECE IS AS
POLICY RESEARCH EVALUATION AND
INNOVATION SO LOOKING AT WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T WORK
THROUGH THROUGH THE EVALUATION
WORK AND MAKING ADJUSTMENTS
ALONG THE WAY HI AFFECTING
POLICY AND PROGRAM. SO THOSE
THREE PIECES ARE EMBEDDED IN
THE NEW DEPARTMENT IN FACT-
IT'S NOT IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BUT- THE INTENTION IS
TO CREATE A TO BUILD THAT INTO
THE STRUCTURE OF THE NEW
DEPARTMENT SO. EVERYTHING THAT
I'VE TALKED ABOUT AROUND-
ACCORDION JOB QUALITY THAT'S
THAT'S THE CORE OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AND ITS WORK. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE WELL
I'M I FOR ONE AM AND TO HEAR
THE PRINCIPLES OF THE ROAD
PARTNERSHIP ARE. THERE IN THE
pEXPLICIT WE KNOW WE HAVE TO.
GET CREATE MORE GOOD PAYING
JOBS IN THE STATE THEY'RE FAR
MORE PEOPLE. WHO NEED AND WANT
A GOOD BETTER PAYING JOBS SO.
WE'VE GOT TO DO WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH INDUSTRY
EMPLOYERS. AND AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS OF. ANY ANY WAY THAT
WE COULD CONNECT INTO THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF AND- THEY
USUALLY ARE THE HARDEST HIT BUT
DON'T GET THE BENEFIT OF A LOT
OF. A LOT OF PROGRAMS- THAT TO
ME IS OF SHOULD BE THE CORE OF
THIS NEW DEPARTMENT OF
CONSOLIDATING THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT- SO I'D LIKE THE
FACT THAT THERE'S REATER FOCUS
AND ATTENTION AND LEADERSHIP
AND- THAT. BOTH LABOR AND
BUSINESS AND OTHERS ARE.
PORTABLE THIS THAT'S A GOOD
SIGN UP TO SEE THAT SO- JUST A
FEW OF MY COMMENTS- SENATORS
YES CENTER NEWMAN PLEASE- TO
THANK HIM OUT OF HERE SO- AS IT
HAPPENS I ACTUALLY HAVE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS THE
SENATE. REPRESENT OF THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND IT-
MISTER ENRIGHT HAD SOME VERSION
THIS CONVERSATION SO I WANT TO-
REAFFIRM I THINK YOU'VE MADE A
VERY CLEAR AND ARTICULATE
SUMMARY OF THE STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES TO BE SOLVED- I HAVE
SOME. THE FAIRLY DEEP
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
VETERANS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PRIOR TO BEING
ELECTED. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IT
IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE THERE IF
THERE ARE TOO MANY INPUTS- YOU
HAVE TOO MANY ENTITIES THAT
WORKING AT CROSS PURPOSES IN
SOME CASES. WELL COMPETING WITH
EACH OTHER AT THE EXPENSE OF-
EITHER AN EMPLOYER A JOB SEEKER
FINDING THOSE PPORTUNITIES AND
PATHWAYS TO MAKE THEIR WAY- AND
SO I APPLAUD YOU MISTER RANEY
FOR MAKING THIS EFFORT I THINK
CLEARLY THERE IS A PROBLEM
NEEDING SOLVING- IN THIS IS A
FIRST ABOUT AND I FEEL KIND OF
WEIRD SAYING THIS BUT I DO HAVE
TO SAY- I THINK THIS IS A
TERRIBLE NAME FOR IT APART. AND
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S COME UP
AND BUT YOU KNOW IT INFORMED
LIKE THIS BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
BETTER JOBS AND HIGHER WAGES- I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO
PUT IT BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
SOMETHING YOU MIGHT SEE ON THE
OFFICE AND I WORRY A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- YOU KNOW HOW THESE
THINGS ARE RECEIVED AND SO I
WOULD URGE. ANYBODY INVOLVED IN
THIS INTERVIEW WITH THE ACRONYM
THE DB T. H. W. IS RUNNING ON A
LITTLE BIT RIGHT SO THAT LAST
NIGHT- HANDICAP ANOTHER WAS
VERY. ADMIRABLE EFFORT WITH A
LESS THAN IDEAL NAME. OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NO
CALMENT WE WILL IN AS GOOD A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
RESPOND TO THAT OKAY- ANY
SENATE CENTER GROVE PLEASE. HER
TO REGAIN MY COMPOSURE THERE
JUST THAT I. THIS POINT WELL
TAKEN I AM SO I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I DO FIND
MYSELF SIDING WITH THE
DIFFERENT WITH THE L. A. O.'S
OFFICE BECAUSE I DO HAVE A
CONCERN THAT IF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALIGNED AT
THE TOP IS IT GOING TO ACTUALLY
FILTER DOWN AND AFFECT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE
IN A CONSTITUENTS COME IN AND-
YOU KNOW. FILE FOR THE
SERVICES. IT IT'S ALL WELL AND
GOOD THAT YOU'RE ORGANIZED AT
THE TOP BUT IF IT DOESN'T
FILTER DOWN TO THE VERY LOCAL
LEVEL WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
HAVE ACCESS TO. APPLYING FOR
THESE BENEFITS IN THESE
PROGRAMS IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
BENEFICIAL. AND ON THE- ABOUT
BDD OFFICE AND IN REMOVING. OR
MOVING WHAT WAS IT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED OR SIXTEEN HUNDREDS.
STAFF I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
MEETING WITH THE NEW DIRECTOR
OR THE NEW AT THE PERSON. I
THINK IT'S A DIRECTOR TITLE
OVER THE EDT. AND I FINALLY
THINK WE HAVE SOME VERY STRONG
LEADERSHIP THERE THAT COULD
POSSIBLY HELP CLEAN UP THIS
DISASTER. THAT ALL OF US AS-
LEGISLATORS ARE DEALING WITH. I
MEAN I KNOW IN MY AREA. IT'S
THE NUMBER ONE PHONE CALL
COMING INTO MY OFFICE IS THAT.
A DELAYED BENEFITS THE BACK
LIKE IF IT IF IT'S THE FRAUD
AND BENEFITS AND- EVERYTHING
SO. I WOULD OT LIKE AGAIN
AGREEING WITH THE- L. A. OZARK.
I WOULD NOT LIKE THIS BRAND NEW
ADMINISTRATOR.A DIRECTOR- THAT
HAS BEEN PUT IN CHARGE THAT I
THINK HAS THE- GIFTS AND
TALENTS. TO STRAIGHTEN THIS OUT
TO BE FOCUSED ON TRANSITIONING
SIXTEEN HUNDRED. MEMBERS OUR
STAFF. TO A NEW. WHEN YOU CALL
IT SIR JOBS. WAS A CALLED. D.
B. W. DVJ W. W. AND I WOULD
REALLY TO KNOW. I I'D LIKE YOU
TO EXPAND ON IT BECAUSE I DO
HAVE A CONCERN OF THE L. A. AS
OFFICE. THAT I JUST HUGE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU MISTER
RAINY. YES THANK YOU FOR THIS
QUESTION SENATOR- IT WILL
FILTER DOWN ACT THE APPROACH
THAT WE TOOK WAS- THAT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES ARE NOT ALIGNED TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL- AND WE'VE AS I
SAID BEFORE WE DID WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK OVER THE YEARS TO
IMPROVE- THE ALIGNMENT AT THE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND PUT A
LOT OF ONUS ON LOCAL AGENCIES
TO GET THAT DONE. AND REALIZE
IF WE DON'T DO THAT ALIGNMENT
IN SACRAMENTO WE DON'T WALK THE
TALK WE'RE NEVER GONNA GET SO
THEY'LL DO THE ALIGNMENT NEEDED
AT THE POINT OF SERVICE
DELIVERY- SO WE KIND OF REVERSE
ENGINEER THAT AT SOME POINT TO
DEAL WITH THE ALIGNMENT HERE
TAKE ON OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
DO THAT- HOPEFULLY WORK WITH
CONGRESS TO DO THE SAME THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO THAT THE
STRINGS ATTACHED TO THESE
PROGRAMS AND FUNDS. ARE EITHER
REMOVED OR LINED AND LESS
BUREAUCRATIC TICK TICK TO
CREATE THAT ACCESS IT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN- I CAN ACT ON THE SECOND
POINT. I COULDN'T AGREE WITH
YOU MORE ABOUT DIRECTOR SIGNS-
THE INCREDIBLY TALENTED- GREAT
LEADERSHIP- AND WE'RE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH DIRECTOR-SCIENCE WILL CONTINUE TO WHICH
IS ALSO ON THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD- TO ENSURE
THAT WE ALLOW HER ALL OF THE
TIME. AND ENERGY NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS THAT SHE'S
THAT SHE IS ADDRESSING NOW- AND
FOCUS THE WORK FOR STUFF.
THROUGH THIS DEPARTMENT
CONSOLIDATION- SEPARATELY SO
THAT IT ALSO GETS THE ATTENTION
IT NEEDS SO THAT WORKERS CAN
GET THE ATTENTION THEY NEED THE
SUPPORT BUSINESSES CAN ALSO SO
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU-
YOUR ASSESSMENT OF DIRECTOR
SCIENCE I THANK YOU FOR THE
PER. OF HER LAST NAME I WAS
GONNA. RE IT BUT I ABOUT WOULD
BE COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE BUT
I WASN'T SURE HOW TO. PRONOUNCE
HER LAST NAME- YES I AGREE WITH
YOU I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WHEN I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH HER. BUT AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THAT. MAYBE THIS
IS NOT THE RIGHT TIME I MEAN
LET'S GIVE HER THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLEAR UP THE BACKLOG SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
STILL WAITING THERE'S OVER A
MILLION PEOPLE. THAT ARE STILL
WAITING FOR BENEFITS AND I KNOW
EDT IS THE NEXT- ITEM THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP WHICH I
THREE I'M SURE WILL BE LEGALLY.
AND I JUST DON'T KNOW THAT THIS
IS THE RIGHT TIME TO DO THAT. I
AM VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HER FOCUS BEING TAKEN OFF OF.
AT A GETTING BENEFITS OUT THE
DOOR. VALID BENEFITS OUT THE
DOOR. AND VALLEY BENEFITS OUT
THE DOOR TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT ARE DESPERATELY STILL
WAITING FOR THOSE RESOURCES.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
SENATOR- DOES- FINANCE ONE TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THE SENATORS-
QUESTIONS. OR ADD. HI MARC
BERMAN OF THE PERMANENT FINANCE
I'M JUST ANTED TO REITERATE
THAT I'VE JUST ABOUT WHAT KIND
OF MISTER SIMMERING YOU HAD-
DESCRIBE- WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
I'VE THAT IMPACTS TO EDT IF
ANYTHING WE HOPE THAT THESE
EFFICIENCIES PAWLOWSKI WHO ARE
FOCUSED ON DEPLOYING- VALUE I
BENEFITS AND- AND OTHER
SERVICES AND A LOT OF THE WORK
FORCE I SYSTEMS TO ALSO.
OPERATE EFFICIENTLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL FIX
LEARN MORE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON A COLLEAGUES THEN
WE WILL MOVE ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN. HERE HE SUGGESTED A
QUICK COM IN SUPPORT OF. MR
RAINEY'S RESPONSE SO WE ARE WE
DO HAVE TO SOLVE THE E. D.
CRISIS AND RIGHT AND I THINK
THE- DIRECTOR SIGNS AND NINETY
FIRST BUNCH OTHERS ARE DOING
THAT. BUT LONGER TERM IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A ZERO SUM
PROPOSITION A AND I THINK I
WOULD AGREE WITH WITH THE
ASSERTION THAT MOVING FORWARD
WE SHOULD GET TO A POINT WHERE
WE CAN SEPARATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FROM BENEFITS- IN A
WAY THAT SERVES BOTH GOALS.
WELL BUT YOU KNOW AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE CURRENT CRISIS
LET'S KEEP THAT IN MIND. THANK
YOU. YEP GOOD POINT THANK YOU
FOR MUCH. NEWMAN ALL RIGHT WE
MOVE ON THEN TO- ISSUE TWELVE-
FIFTH. SCHOOL WILL PRESENT ON
ISSUE. TWELVE GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM CALEB HORRELL
CHIEF OF THE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM DIVISION FOR THE
IMPLANT. THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT TE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET REQUEST.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO MAKE THE FIRST
INTEREST PAYMENT ON A FEDERAL
LOAN THE STATE RECEIVED IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE PAYING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
AFTER THE U. I. FUND BECAME
INSOLVENT AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WHEN THE STATE'S YOU
I TRUST FUND BECOMES INSOLVENT
THE STATE IS STILL OBLIGATED BY
FEDERAL LAW TO PAY BENEFITS TO
ELIGIBLE WORKERS. THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION BEGINNING IN JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
SUBSTITUTING A LOAN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN ORDER FOR
THE STATE TO KEEP UP. WITH
PAYING BENEFITS TO ELIGIBLE
WORKERS. WE RECOGNIZE AND AS
LA- NOTES IN THERE RIGHT UP.
THAT THE INITIAL ESTIMATE WHICH
WAS PREDICATED ON A FAIRLY
PESSIMISTIC ECONOMIC OUTLOOK.
AND DID NOT INCLUDE RECENT LOAN
INTEREST FORGIVENESS THAT WAS
PASSED. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY- WILL BE LOWER
COME SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHEN THE PAYMENT IS
ALTERNATELY DO- ADDITIONALLY
IT'S ALSO WORTH POINTING OUT
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CAL THE
NINETEEN RELIEF PACKAGE. THAT
IS MAKING ITS WAY TO FEDERAL
LEVEL DOES CONTAIN FURTHER
INTEREST RELIEF FOR STATE-
THROUGH THE END OF AUGUST WHICH
COULD ULTIMATELY MEAN ONLY ONE
MONTH OF BORROWING. IN THE
FIRST YEAR FOR STATES- THE
DEPARTMENT WILL UPDATE THE
ESTIMATED LOAN INTEREST AMOUNT
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S NEAR
VISION. AND WE FURTHER UPDATED
BASED ON PROPOSED BUDGET
LANGUAGES THE PAYMENT DATE GETS
NEAR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
AND I ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM EDT. ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IT WAS. THE EIGHT L. A. O. HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. S. CHANNEL WITH
THE L. A. L- THROUGH MINDFUL
THAT THE LANDSCAPE ISSUES
SHIFTING HERE AS MR HORRELL
MENTION GIVEN- POTENTIAL
FEDERAL CHANGES AND I FEDERAL
CHANGE THAT'S HAPPENED SINCE
THE ADMINISTRATION DEVELOPED
THIS ESTIMATE IN PARTICULAR ON
THE TWO POINTS THAT WERE RAISED
BY MISTER CORAL FIRST AND
FOREMOST THAT THE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INTEREST PAYMENT. IS BASED ON
WHAT IS NOW OUTDATED ECONOMIC
INFORMATION AND SECONDLY THAT
THE INTEREST WAIVER WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY EXTENDED TO MARCH
FIFTEENTH TAKING THOSE TWO
PIECES INTO ACCOUNT OUR OFFICE
ESTIMATES. THAT THE INTEREST
PAYMENTS ARE COMING IN
SEPTEMBER WILL BE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
RATHER THAN FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS-
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A
PROVISION OF FEDERAL LAW WHICH
WILL ALLOW THE STATE GIVEN ITS
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE
LAST YEAR TO DEFER A PORTION OF
THIS UPCOMING INTEREST PAYMENTS
COULD TO FOR THREE QUARTERS OF
THE UPCOMING PAYMENT. AND PAY
EACH OF THOSE. ON PAY A PORTION
OF THE TO. IN EACH OF THE THREE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS- AND THERE'S
NO FISCAL PENALTY FOR THE STATE
FOR DOING THIS I AM SO WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE THIS
TIME TO ADOPT A SMALLER BUDGET
AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND
ADDITIONALLY- PURSUE THE
INTEREST DEFERRAL TAKING BOTH
THOSE ACTIONS TOGETHER. I WOULD
WE ESTIMATE. RESULT IN INTEREST
PAYMENTS DUE IN THE BUDGET YEAR
OF SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
ON MINDFUL OF THESE ESTIMATES
AS MISTER WORLD MENTIONED OUR
OFFICE WILL BE LOOKING AGAIN AT
THESE NUMBERS AS WELL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS PART
OF THE MAY REVISION HELLO WE
HAVE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
ASPECTS OF INTAKE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THAT MIGHT EXPECT
THESE NUMBERS. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M SORRY IS THERE
ANYONE FROM ET DE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. COMMENT NO I'M SORRY-
SENATE CALL FINANCE OKAY SO
FINANCE. THERE WAS A TV.
EARLIER I ALOMAR COMMANDERS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE THAT WE
WILL BE UPDATING THE SPEAKERS
IN THE MAY REVISE WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT ON
THE L. A. L. HAD JUST THAT AT
DESCRIBING AND EXPLAINED AND
WERE HAPPY TO- REVIEW THOSE
PROPOSALS AND FEEDBACK AND TAKE
IT INTO CONSIDERATION AS WE
DEVELOP THE MAY BE QUITE. HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS YES YES CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I HAD AN-
AND I AM AT ACTING ON BEHALF OF
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO IS
NOT- ON THIS COMMITTEE SENATOR
NELSON WOULD LIKE THIS LETTER-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR SUBMITTED TO THE
RECORD- AT REGARDING THE AUDIT
AND THE- THE ISSUES OF THE
AUDITOR HAD BROUGHT IT
REGARDING AND THAT. DEAD
DEFICIENCIES AT THE EDT
DEPARTMENT AND I ALSO HAVE A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS THAT HE
WOULD ASK HE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
ASK- A. THESE QUESTIONS THAT HE
WANTS WITH US ARE NOT RELATED
TO THE LETTER THEIR SEPARATE
THE LETTER BUT HE ASKED ME TO
SUBMIT THE LETTER BASED ON WHAT
THE AUDITOR HAD SAID AND I
THINK ALL OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE READ THAT-
AUDITOR'S LETTER BECAUSE THERE
IS A SUBSTANTIAL ISSUES GOING
ON WITH EDT LIKE I SAID EARLIER
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT
THAT COMES INTO THE OFFICE. IS
IT SENATOR NELSON LIKE TO HAVE
ACCESS THAT- EDT- INDIVIDUALS
CALL OUR OFFICES REGARDING ET
DE IN THE AT AND TRY TO GET US
TO SYSTEM THE COMPLAINTS. PATH
IS AVAILABLE FOR EDT CALL
CENTERS FOR STAFF TO ESCALATE
MORE DIFFICULT CLAIMS AND MOVE
MORE EXPERIENCED A TO MORE
EXPERIENCE ET STAFF. AS I GUESS
THE REAL ISSUE IS THAT- WHEN
THERE IS SOMEONE WHO WAS
INITIALLY DENIED THEY CALL OUR
OFFICE OR WHEN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
A BACKLOG FOR THEIR BUT THEIR
EDT BENEFITS HAVE BEEN DELAYED
THEY CALL THE OFFICE AND- WE
DON'T MIND I MEAN HELPING WITH
EDT ISSUES. THAT'S PART OF OUR
JOB THAT'S WHY WE HAVE FIELD
REPRESENTATIVES AND STAFF TO
HELP BUT ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT AS SENATOR NIELSEN HAS IS
THAT- THERE'S- NOT VERY MANY
PHONE CALLS BEING RETURNED.
THAT PEOPLE DON'T HEAR
RESPONSES BACK- SOME OF THEM
SINCE JANUARY SECOND AND
PREVIOUS TO THAT. DECEMBER IN
THE DECEMBER TIME FRAME- CALLS
ARE BEING RETURNED. IN SO
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS HERE
ABOUT HOW OFTEN DOES HE CALL
CENTER STAFF. AT THE THREE
THIRTY JUST IN THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE MATTER WHICH
INFORMATION IS DISSEMINATED
DISSEMINATED TO STAFF. IN THE
DEPARTMENT TRACK THE CALL
CENTER STAFF RESOLUTIONS IN
CASES BECAUSE- IT APPEARS TO US
AS LEGISLATORS THE RESOLUTIONS
FOR CLAIMS ARE NOT BEING DEALT
WITH. AND IS THE DEPARTMENT
GATHERING ANY DATA RELATED TO
COMMON QUESTIONS. TEN MAKING
STAFF- MORE PROPERLY TRAINED
AND BEST PRACTICES SO THAT
COMMON AT QUESTIONS THAT ARE
BEING ASKED BY CONSTITUENTS BUT
WE- ANSWERED THE SAME WAY-
BASICALLY FROM DDD STEPHENS.
GETTING A DIFFERENT ANSWER
EVERY TIME. HIS BIGGEST WAS
CENTER GROVE- I CAN APPRECIATE
ALL THE TO- RELATED. TO ADD.
WORLDBUILDING WITH WITH I WAS
HOPING WE- FOCUS ON THE
PARTICULAR. ISSUE THAT'S BEING
PRESENTED AND HOW DO WE THAT'S
A LOT OF QUESTIONS I'M TRYING
TO THINK OF THE WAY TO. ANSWER
THOSE GET ANSWERS FOR YOU. BUT
THEN HI THE STAY FOCUSED HERE
ON THE ISSUE OF THIS INTEREST
INTEREST PAYMENT YEAH. AND HERE
VERY MENTION AND I AM LIKE I
SAID DOING A SERVICE TO MY
COLLEAGUE THE ENERGY THIS LET.
AND I WILL HONOR YOUR- YOUR- SO
WE COULD. GET THAT SOMEHOW.
RESPONSE RESPONSES FROM- EDT TO
SENATOR. QUESTIONS BUT TODAY WE
COULD HEAR- FOCUS MORE ON
ISSUES OF WHETHER OR NOT THIS
AND HOW MUCH THE INTEREST
PAYMENT WOULD BE. THAT MAKES
SENSE ABSOLUTELY I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISSY WHO IS GOING
TO LIVE THERE ANYMORE. COMMENTS
NO OKAY WELL I THINK WE WOULD
LIKE TO PAY OUT AS LITTLE AS WE
HAVE TO WE'VE GOT SOME GOOD
GOOD NEWS THERE ON ON THAT
FRONT- WE'RE NOT OUT OF TROUBLE
OF FOR SURE BECAUSE WE STILL
OWE A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT-
AT LEAST WITH REGARDS TO THE
INTEREST PAYMENT I THINK. THE
BETTER NEWS- OKAY. IF THERE'S
NO MORE. MY CALL. THEN WILL
MOVE. TO ISSUE THIRTEEN PLEASE.
MORNING HI KATIE HAGEN DIRECTOR
OF INVESTOR RELATIONS- MORNING
SENATORS- THIS THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE THE FREE TODAY
RESTORATION ENHANCEMENT OF
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH SAFETY AND
HEALTH PROGRAM- THIS REQUEST-
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL
OFFER RATES UPTO SEVENTY
PHYSICIANS AND- FOURTEEN
MILLION FOUR- FROM THE-
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
FUND. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THIRTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION I'M GOING TO ADDRESS A
CRITICAL STAFF SHORTAGE OF
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST AND SAFETY
ENGINEERS THAT HELLO SHOT- AS
OUTLINED IN THE B. C. P. WE
HAD- INDEPENDENT STUDY
IDENTIFIED A POTENTIAL NEED FOR
AS MANY AS TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT. ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TAKING THESE
STUDY RESULTS UNDER ADVISEMENT-
AND WE PLANNED TO REQUEST
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS I'M IN IT
IN FUTURE YEARS- THE BOTTOM THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS IDENTIFIED
IN THAT STUDY- SUPPORTED
FUNDING- CALIFORNIA STATE PLAN-
BY FEDERAL OSHA. WHICH WOULD
BRING IT TO THE LEVEL THAT THEY
DEFINE AS AT LEAST AS EFFECTIVE
AS THE THIRD LANGUAGE- OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM SO. SO THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY- SUPPORTS THE
FEDERAL OSHA- PLAN
REQUIREMENTS. AND I'M ONE I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION THAT THE
STUDY HAVE BEEN IN THE WORKS
PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC AND- I- IT WAS FINE. I
THINK A MONTH AFTER SORT OF- HE
WAS IN A OF YEAR. SO THE IMPACT
OF THAT CAN WAS CONSIDERED IT
WAS THE NEED WAS THERE EVEN
PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF COVERT
NINETEEN I'M IN AS MANY OF YOU
ARE UNDOUBTEDLY AWARE CAL OSHA
HAS LONG BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
CRITICISM FOR NOT HAVING.
SUFFICIENT STAFF TO DELIVER ITS
CORE FUNCTION OF PROVIDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS ACROSS-
OCCUPATIONS. AND INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE BEEN A NUMBER
OF- THAT KELLER SHOULD HAVE
SPACED OVER SEVERAL YEARS MANY
YEARS. WITH STAFFING
SPECIFICALLY- AND WE ADDED SOME
VERY KEY LANGUAGE IN THAT-
BUDGET PROPOSAL REFERENCING- I
PLAN TO WORK WITH CALLIE JAR-
IN THE FUTURE. TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT ARMS HARD
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WE USE- AT
SPECIFICALLY THE INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST AND IT'S SALARY
RANGE- THERE'S A LOT OF HISTORY
THERE ON THE YA- AREN'T WE HAD-
THANKS A HUNDRED PER. I TRY OF
OUR DOES HER HI JOE OVER THE
LAST YEARS WE DO HAVE-
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENISTS THAT WORK
FOR CAL OSHA BUT THEY ARE IN A
DIFFERENT CLASSIFICATION- AND I
BECAUSE THE SALARY OF THE
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENISTS JUST
WASN'T. ATTRACTIVE ENOUGH IN
OUR HIGH JENIS OPTED TO MOVE TO
ANOTHER CLASSIFICATION- SO WE
DON'T WANT HISTORY TO REPEAT
ITSELF AND- I BE UNABLE TO
RETAIN- THESE VERY HECTIC.
PERSONNEL AND THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR WORKFORCE- SO WE
HAVE PLANS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT SORT OF. THE- TOP END UP
THE PAY SCALE THAT WOULD WOULD
BE IMPORTANT AND RETAINING
STAFF. SO FAR I'VE BEEN
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO TRACK- THREE FIX
STAFF INTO THE INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST. CLASSIFICATION AS
WELL AS OUR SAFETY ENGINEER
CLASSES ACROSS THE STATE WE'VE
BEEN- ABLE TO HIRE- I THINK
LAST WEEK WHEN I LOOKED WE HAD
ABOUT THIRTY- STAFF THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE HIGHER OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS- AND- WE STILL
HAVEAPPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE-
ENFORCEMENT VACANCIES THAT WE
NEED TO FILL IN CALIFORNIA- AND
THOSE ARE ALL UNDER WAY- AT
SOME POINT IN THE- THE HIRING
PIPELINE- TO FILL THOSE. WE ARE
GETTING A FEW PEOPLE THAT ARE
TURNING US DOWN BUT- BUT
OVERALL WE'VE WE- ARE DOING
WELL WITH OUR RECRUITMENT. AND
IN ADDITION TO THE RECRUITMENT
CHALLENGES ISSUE PROBABLY AWARE
THE DEPARTMENTS HAD A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF- IT'S
LOSS OF HIGH. US HAVE SOME GOOD
ON THAT FRONT THAT- WERE BEING
HEARD NEXT WEEK AT THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD. I'M
CONSIDERING OUR PETITION TO
REQUEST RETURN OF OUR HIRING
AUTHORITY SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
THAT WILL SOON BE RESTORED FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS. AND AS PART OF
THAT RETURN OF A STORY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON
ESTABLISHING ALL NEW
EXAMINATIONS THAT ARE ONLINE-
AND AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. TO ANY INTERESTED CLASS
PARTY TO APPLY FOR JOBS. WE PUT
TOGETHER AN ASIAN WIDE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS- FOR SAFETY
ENGINEERS A HYGIENIST AND- A
NUMBER OF OUR SPORT POSITIONS
ATTORNEYS LEADERSHIP- NOT AND
THEN FINALLY I JUST WANTED TO.
THAT IN IT TO ALL OF THE
RECRUITING AND HIGHER EFFORTS
AND THE SALARY- REVIEW THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT FURTHER DOWN
THE ROAD. I WE REALLY NEED TO-
BALANCE SERVING THE
CONSTITUENTS OF CALIFORNIA. I
AND CAN YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT
WORK WITH WEEK CONDUCTING
HIRING INTERVIEWS AND- YOU KNOW
THESE ARE THE SAME SUPERVISORS
THAT ARE REVIEWING ALL OF OUR
CITATIONS PROVIDING GUIDANCE
TO. INDUSTRIES SO- IT'S A
DELICATE BALANCE BUT ONE THAT
WE ARE TAKING VERY SERIOUSLY WE
HAVE A WEEKLY PROJECT
MANAGEMENT MEETINGS HELLO STAFF
TALK DAILY ABOUT HIRING FOCUS-
SO WE'RE SO WE- ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO FILL
THOSE REMAINING FORTY FIVE
ENFORCEMENT VACANCIES VERY SAM.
WITH THAT I WILL PAUSE. TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF. FIVE HI THERE-
COUNTRY POP THE FARM OF FINANCE-
OKAY WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ADVERTISEMENT AGAIN
HAVING ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY AND THE A. O. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE A. R. WE NOTICED
CONCERNS A PROPOSED- TO POINT
OUT IT'S A MALL YEAR- SO BE
CONTINUING THIS AND THE FUTURE
AND TO WORK WITH A AND TO A
SORT OF FACILITATE THAT
CONVERSATION. OKAY I HAVE A
COUPLE OF. QUESTIONS ONE IS-
GIVEN THAT ONLY FIVE POINT 5%
OF COVERT NINETEEN COMPLAINTS
ABOUT WERE INSPECTED. HOW ARE
WE NOT CAN YOU EXPLAIN. I KNOW
YOU TOUCHED ON IT BUT HOW COME
WE'RE NOT MAKING OR HOW DO WE
MAKE ADDITIONAL PROGRESS
TOWARDS REACHING THE BENCHMARK
WHAT IS IT A HUNDRED AND EIGHT-
ADDITIONAL HIGH GENEST AND
THIRTY NINE ADDITIONAL WHAT IS
THE S. E. SAFETY YES. OF EVERY
WORD WE WON'T WE WON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO FIVE POINT 5% OF
THE KOBE COMPLAINTS- INSPECT
THEM SO. HOW DO WE MOVE FASTER
TOWARDS WHO REALLY WERE THE
BENCHMARK WE SUPPOSED TO BE.
I'M I THINK I MAY ASK MY
COLLEAGUE DOUG PARKER TO HELP-
RESPOND TO THE FIRST PART OF
YOUR QUESTION WHICH IS. ODD
THAT THE 5% OF THE COATED-
RESPONSES I THINK IT'S MORE
COMPLEX THAN A STAFFING ISSUE-
BUT I DON'T KNOW DONE DO YOU
HAVE- ANY INSIGHT TO SHARE WITH
THE PANEL. I CAN'T THANK YOU
SENATOR- LOS TO. AS AS- AS AS
WE DISCUSSED IN PRIOR HEARINGS
YOU KNOW CAL OSHA HAS HAD A
VERY HIGH VOLUME OF WORKLOAD
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO-
CODE NINETEEN COMPLAINTS. THIS
YEAR- YET TO DATE SINCE
FEBRUARY WE'VE HAD TWELVE
THOUSAND TO ALMOST TWELVE
THOUSAND COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED COMPLAINTS ARE THAT'S
TYPICALLY NO MORE THAN THE
NUMBER OF WORKER COMPLAINTS
THAT WE GET FOR ALL REASONS IN
THE COURSE OF A TYPICAL YEAR.
AND SO THAT'S YOU KNOW REFLECTS.
THE- JUST THE- DOUBLE WORK THAT
THAT COVER NINETEEN ROCK. I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO IT DRESSED NOT JUST
BECOME BUT OUR TO INVESTIGATE
OUTBREAKS TO INVESTIGATE
SERIOUS ILLNESSES AND TO
INVESTIGATE THE TECHNOLOGIES.
WE PUT IN PLACE A TRIAGE SYSTEM
IN WHICH WE- IT INITIAL
EVALUATIONS OF- OF COVERT
NINETEEN COMPLAINTS THROUGH
WHATEVER A REMOTE INVESTING
PROCESS USING A LETTER AND
USING PHONE CONTACT EMPLOYERS
AND CHECK WITH WORKERS TO
DETERMINE IF ISSUES COULD BE
RESOLVED AND- I MAKE NO-
REPRESENT. THAT THAT'S-
EQUIVALENT TO AN IN PERSON
INVESTIGATION IT WOULD CLEARLY
BE BETTER IF WE COULD DO MORE
IN PERSON INVESTIGATIONS AND WE
ARE WORKING A NUMBER OF ANGLES
TO DO THAT- INCLUDING YES
WORKING ON HOW WE CAN SIMPLIFY
OUR- OUR- YOU KNOW OUR
INSPECTION EFFORTS WERE WERE
ACTUALLY ALSO- YEAH- WORK ON-
ON ON THAT'S NOT AS AS WE SEE-
BUT YOU KNOW RECOGNIZED THAT WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE THIS VERY
YES I CHALLENGES- AND WE PUT
THE TRIAGE METHOD IN PLACE AND
WE STILL GO OUT AND CONDUCT.
INSPECTIONS ON- ON ON
COMPLAINTS WHERE IT'S AN
EXTREMELY SERIOUS COMPLAINT-
WHERE IT- IS COMBINED WITH AN
ILLNESS WHERE THERE'S AN
OUTBREAK OR WHERE THE EMPLOYER%
DOESN'T STATUS YOU KNOW GIVE US
A SATISFACTORY RESPONSE AND
WE'RE WORKING TOWARD A MUCH
BETTER YOU KNOW WE'D LIKE TO
SEE A MUCH BETTER RATIO. OF
COMPLAINTS WERE IN THE PROCESS
OF- THAT'S GOING BACK IN AND RE
INVESTIGATING SOME OF THOSE.
COMPLAINTS AS A COMPLIANCE
CHECK TO SEE THAT EMPLOYERS DID
IN FACT DO WHAT THEY SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO DO AS A RESULT OF
OUR REMOTE INVESTIGATIONS- SO-
AND AT AND WHILE WE ONLY- WHAT
WE'VE ONLY DONE FIVE. OF THOSE
COMPLAIN. WE DO HAVE AN- HIGH
NUMBER OF FATALITIES AND- AND
OF COURSE OUTBREAKS THAT WE'VE
HAD TO INVESTIGATE. IT THIS
YEAR AND- SO THOSE INSPECTION
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN KIND OF
REALLOCATED FROM COMPLAINTS TO.
THE VERY IMPORTANT NEED TO
INVESTIGATE WORKER DEATHS. OKAY
WELL HOW OBVIOUSLY ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF COVERT NINETEEN.
YOUR WORK ON YOUR DEPARTMENTS
WORK IS SO CRITICAL BERMAN HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH. WHAT
THEN HAPPENS OF WITH THOSE
EMPLOYEES. WHEN THEY GO HOME
AND THE SPREAD THAT IT DOES TO
THE TO THE FAMILY I KNOW I READ
RECENTLY A STATISTIC ABOUT- IN
ORDER FOR ITS JUST A LOS
ANGELES BUT- OF THE- PERCENTAGE
OF MULTIPLE EARNERS WITHIN A
SINGLE HOUSEHOLD. UP WAS DOUBLE
THAT OF ANY OTHER COMMUNITY
AND- SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THEIR EXPOSURE WHEN YOU GET
MULTIPLE EARNERS OUT ON THE
JOBS AND THEN COMING HOME THAT
THAT EXPOSURE REALLY I BELIEVE.
IS PART OF THE ISSUE THAT HAS
LED TO SUCH DOUBLE AND TRIPLE
NUMBER OF CASES AND DEATHS- SO
THERE'S A- DIRECT CONNECTION I
HAVE IMPROVED IT BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THERE'S A DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS. AND
HEALTH PROTOCOLS AND OF THE
IMPACT THAT IT HAS ON THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR NEIGHBORS
AND THEIR AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO. YOUR WORK. HIS SOUL FOR
CRITICAL AND SOME POINTED
ENTIRE- SENATE YES SENATOR
COURTESY THANK YOU A MEASURE
JUST HAVE A QUICK THAT IS JUST
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THE
HISTORY OF IT- THE HIRING THE-
ISSUE WITH HIRING GO THROUGH.
DEAL WHAT HOW HAS THAT BEEN
THE CASE OR IF I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR THE TO ME VERSION OF- THE
HIS OF THAT IF YOU IF SOMEBODY
CAN THAT FOR ME. I CAME HAGAN I
PART OF INVESTOR RELAY- HIRING
AUTHORITY WEST LAW- IT'S BEEN A-
APPROXIMATELY TWO. AGO NOW- AS
A RESULT OF AN AUDIT OF-
ILLEGAL. PRACTICES BY PRAIRIE-
AND- B. R. SO DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR YES YOU BE THE STAND OUT
MORE YOU BE THE TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. THE HIGHER
PER. GOING BACK OF YEARS TO THE
PRO MINISTRY I THINK WAS THE
ANSWER. IS THAT CORRECT.
PRACTICE RIGHT. YEAH I CAN.
LEARN ABOUT THAT OFFLINE IJUST
WANT TO KNOW FOR THANK YOU.
TRUMP OKAY SANDERS SENATOR- NO
MORE OKAY THANK YOU MCH. FOR
ALL OF TWO ISSUE FOR. EARNED-
BERMAN FOR SPECIAL APPAREL.
COULD THE DEPARTMENT PRESENT
PLEASE. I THINK YOU AND I'M
GONNA DEFERRED MY COLLEAGUE
LABOR A LITTLE YOUNGER BROWER
TO ENTER THIS. AS REFLECTED IN
THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PROVIDED LAST
YEAR THE APPROPRIATION OF
GENERAL FUND MONIES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ALSO APPROVED
TO ALLOW FOR FUND TRANSFERS TO
THE GARMENT ON AS NEEDED. HAS
PROVIDED SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO
PAY ALL OUTSTANDING CLAIMS AS
WELL AS ALL CAN BE ORDERED FOR
FIFTY FOUR REFERRAL BASED ON
WHAT WE KNOW TODAY. A YES
TECHNICALLY FUND CONSIDERED IS
CONSIDERED TO BE INSOLVENT IN
THAT THE PENDING REFERRAL BOTH
EXCEED AVAILABLE CASH AND
PROJECTED REVENUES INTO THE
FUND. FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR AND
BEYOND. AS OF FEBRUARY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE WAS ONE
POINT THREE SEVEN NINE MILLION
IN THE FUNDS COMPARED TO THE
EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION CLAIMS
PENDING FOR REFERRAL AND
CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW. THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION IN THE UNPAID WORKER
FUND WHICH WILL BE PROCESSED
FOR TRANSFERRED TO THE FUND
PURSUANT TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE. THERE ARE A TOTAL OF
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE CLAIMS FOR
THE AMOUNT OF EIGHT POINT TWO
MILLION. I CAN GO THROUGH THAT
DETAIL THAT TOTAL EIGHT POINT
TWO MILLION CAPTURES INDIVIDUAL
GARMENT CLAIMS ABOUT SEVENTY
THREE INDIVIDUAL CLAIMS. AND IT
ALSO CAPTURES CLEAVES FROM OUR
GARMENTS- FROM OUR BUREAU OF
FIELD FORCE MEN ARE FIELD. THAT
TOTALS THAT HE WENT TO. THANK
YOU I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. OKAY SO THE
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE FIRST
TIME I. REALLY ENCOUNTERED THIS
THIS ISSUE OF I'M SORRY I
ACTUALLY I SHOULD GET-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THEN
LA- AND THEN I'LL ASK A
QUESTION. THE FIRM FINANCE.
FIVE HUNDRED W. BARBARA
FINANCE- BECAUSE APPARENTLY
INFORMATIONAL I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS- BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU AND ALEJO. AS I DON'T
KNOW WITH THE AUDIO- THE SAME
OKAY OKAY THAT'LL MAKE MY
COMMENTS SO COUPLE YEARS AGO-
WAS THE FIRST TIME I'VE- EVEN.
PAID ATTENTION A NEW THAT THIS
SPECIAL FUND EXISTED- BECAUSE
THERE WAS TESTIMONY FROM SOME
GARMENT WORKERS WHO CAME HERE
TO THE CAPITAL. AND ONE AFTER
ANOTHER TESTIFIED THAT THEIR
CLAIMS HAD ALREADY BEEN. A
FINALIZED BONTA THE PROCESS AND
THE AWARD WAS GIVEN AS TO HOW
MUCH WAS OWED TO THEM AND IT
WAS SEVERAL YEARS. THAT EVEN
AFTER THAT CLAIM HAD BEEN
DECIDED THAT THEY STILL WEREN'T
PAID. AND WE WEREN'T MOVING THE
FUNDING BUT THEN AS IT TURNS
OUT THIS RESTITUTION FUND
WASN'T ENOUGH MONEY SO WE WERE
HAVING TO MOVE MORE MONEY INTO
THAT FUND TO BE ABLE TO PAY
THESE CLAIMS- AND I WAS PRETTY.
SURPRISED BY THIS FIRST OF ALL
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY CLAIMS.
THAT THE RESTITUTION FUND
DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
PAY THEM AND THEN SECOND THAT
THESE WORKERS WERE. WAITING
YEARS. TO GET- SOME PORTION OR
ALL HOPEFULLY ALL OF THE MONEY
THAT'S OWED TO THEM AND IT'S
NOT LIKE THEY REACH GOING TO
GET MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I DON'T KNOW
MAYBE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AT
AT AT THE MOST- AND IT WAS
QUITE SHOCKING UNITED TO TELL
YOU THE TRUTH AND- SO WE TRY TO
MOVE TO GET THE MONEY INTO THAT
FUND SO I COULD AT LEAST THEY
COULD- THEY COULD GET THEIR
OWN. AWARDS ON PAID- AND A FEW
MONTHS LATER I WAS THAT- YOU
KNOW SPOKE TO THEM AGAIN AND
SOME OF THEM HAVE GONE PAYING
SOMEONE HAD NOT IT'S A-
UNBELIEVABLY SLOW. BUT I THINK
AT THE HEART OF IT IS. THAT
THE- THERE'S THIS BACKLOG OF
UNPAID GARMENT WORKER- WAGE
CLAIMS. AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
MONEY IN THE RESTITUTION FUND
SO WE KEEP HAVING TO REPLENISH.
THE RESTITUTION FUND- BECAUSE
THAT THE CLAIMS ARE STILL THERE
SO MANY CLAIMS- HI WHAT. WHAT
DO YOU RECOMMEND OR DO YOU HAVE
A RECOMMENDATION AS TO HOW WE-
ADDRESS THIS BECAUSE- IT SEEMS
LIKE A CRAZY CYCLE. WITH THE
WORKERS. GO TO WORK YOU DON'T
GET PAID. IS WAGE THEFT CLAIMS
IT'S THE ADJUDICATED ITSELF
PROCESS. AND THEY STILL DON'T
GET PAID SO YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
GET PAID FROM THE EMPLOYER
WHO'S PROBABLY. CLOSED DOWN.
AND MOVED DOWN THE BLOCK AND
THEN. YOU HAVE OF. THEM NOT
BEING ABLE TO RECOVER EVEN FROM
OUR OUR STATE FUNDS SO. WHAT
WHAT. WHAT CAN YOU RECOMMEND
THAT WE DO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR- AS YOU WELL KNOW I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN AND I TOO
WAS SHOCKED- BYE AS I LEARNED
MORE ABOUT THE SITUATION IN
PARTICULAR TO THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY- AND I THINK THERE ARE
TWO PIECES I WOULD CAP OR
POSSIBLY THREE WAYS I WOULD
CATEGORIZE WHAT WE'RE DOING. I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
A SUCCESSFUL PARTNER FOR US THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS PART OF THE
BACKLOG USE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
VACANCY RATE AND NOT HAVING
ENOUGH POSITIONS AS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES
INDULGE AND SO WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD- WITH THE STRONG EFFORT
LED BY OUR DIRECTOR IN FULL
CYLLENE SIGNIFICANT BEACON C.
STAND THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE. AND THAT IS A
STRATEGIES VERY SPECIFIC
CORRELATION TO THE BACKLOG OF
THE GARMENT CLAIMS- THEN THERE
IS ANOTHER ISSUE OF REACHING
WORKERS AND HELPING THEM
UNDERSTAND THIS PROCESS SEES
THAT THE STATE HAS THAT ARE NOT
VERY FLEXIBLE THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL HAS TO COMPLY WITH
SO WE DID LAUNCH AN AGGRESSIVE
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN THIS PAST
AUGUST TO REACH DISTRICTS
ESPECIALLY WORKERS WHO ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. AND WE
KNOW THAT THE POPULATION OF THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY ARE IN FACT
THOSE EXACT WORKERS THAT WE
NEED TO REACH WE HAVE WORKING
CLOSLY WITH PARTNERS LIKE THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER AND BAD
STATIC IN THE UCLA UCLA. LABOR
CENTER. PRIESTS ARE OUT WE WITH.
INCREASED SCENES MEDIA SO THAT
THEY CAN. WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AGAINST
WAGE THEFT AND RETALIATION. AND
WE ARE ALSO WORKING TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THEM ABOUT THE-
PURSUING WAGES. AGAINST THE
RESTITUTION FUND WHAT IS THAT
PROCESS AND WE'RE WORKING ON
DEVELOPING MATERIAL THAT
PROVIDES A FLOW CHART THAT IS
MUCH MORE CLEAR FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE THE PAYMENT FROM THE
RESTITUTION FUND. AND THE LAST
PIECE I'D LIKE TO- HIGHLIGHT IS
THAT WE HAVE S. REESTABLISHED
OUR GARMENTS- FIELD ENFORCEMENT
UNIT- AND THAT UNIT WAS
PREVIOUSLY DISBANDED- AND WE
ARE NOW BRINGING THAT UNIT BACK
IN EXACTLY BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM WORKERS AND PARTNERS. AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT THAT UNIT
WILL INCREASE THE OUTCOMES OF
ELIMINATING BACK ACTORS AND
BEING ABLE TO MAXIMIZE OUR
TOOLS TO PUT HARD EARNED MONEY
IN PEOPLE'S POCKETS. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MA'AM SURE I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON AND SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS OR THE
QUESTION THAT- MEDICARE WOMAN
ASKED US. IN A REPORT VIRGINIA-
SKEWS ME JULY JULY A SEVENTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY. YOU PROCESSED-
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
GOVERNMENT CLAIMS THAT ALSO
HAVE TO INNER CITY CLAIMS IN
PROCESS. SINCE JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY HOW MANY CLAIMS HAVE
BEEN PROCESSED. OUT OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO I'M INTERESTED IN NO.
AND IF TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
PEOPLE ARE STILL WAITING. OR
HAVE THEY BEEN TAKING CARE OF.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO NOT HAVE
THAT INFORMATION DIRECTLY IN
FRONT OF ME SO I CAN SHARE THAT
WITH YOU. I WILL RESTATE THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHT ACTIVE GARMENT CLAIMS
IN THE PROCESS SO THOSE ARE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHT INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE GOING THROUGH. THE PROCESS
TO RECOVER UNPAID WAGES. M.
JUST TO CLARIFY I GUESS I MAY
HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD IT SO IN
JULY A TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY AND
NOW THERE'S TWO HUNDRED EIGHT I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS IT. DO YOU
THINK THOSE ARE NEW CLAIMS OR
IS THAT PART OF THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY CLAIMS THAT WERE IN
JULY THAT HAD NOT BEEN PAID.
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE. HOW
MANY PEOPLE IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
DO YOU HAVE PROCESSING THESE
CLAIMS FOR. EIGHT MONTHS TO
ONLY GET SIXTY DONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR OUR WAGE CLAIM
ADJUDICATION UNIT IS OUR
LARGEST UNIT WITHIN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE WE ARE
FUNDED FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR FULL TIME POSITIONS
WE DO HAVE A 32% BEACON C. RATE
WE HAVE ABOUT I RECALL I THINK
TWELVE INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
GARMENT ENFORCEMENT UNIT. THAT
FOCUS ON THE JUDICATA MEANING
GARMENT ENFORCEMENT CLAIMS TO
GIVE YOU A BACKGROUND ON THIS
THOSE NUMBERS OF STAFFING. IT
IS LIKELY THAT SOME OF THESE
CURRENT TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT
CASES ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS
FROM THOSE JULY TWO HUNDRED
CASES AND OUR TEAM DOES HAVE
THAT INFORMATION I JUST DO NOT
HAVE IT AVAILABLE FOR YOU BUT I
CAN PROVIDE YOU A DETAILED
BREAKDOWN. UNFORTUNATELY AS
SENATOR DID ALSO MENTIONED IT
DOES TAKE- A YEAR TO TWO YEARS
OF FOR A CLEAN TO WORK THROUGH
OUR PROCESS AND WE SHARE THE
LEGISLATURE SINCE ARMED WITH
THAT WHICH IS WHY WE PURSUED
SIGNIFICANT STAFFING RESOURCES
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND WE ARE NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF HIRING THOSE
POSITIONS TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE
THE BACKLOG. IS RIGHT BUT I
ADD- ALSO ANOTHER POINT THAT
WHEN I LOOKED INTO THIS ISSUE
AYE- I THINK IT ADDS TO THE
SORT OF THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
SITUATION AND THAT- MANY OF THE
WORKERS I AND THAT YOU KNOW
SUBMIT APPLICATIONS ARE WORKERS
AND- OTHER AREAS OF THE COUNTRY
THEY GO BACK TO THEIR COUNTRIES
OF ORIGIN SOMETIMES AND WE
OFTEN LOSE CONTACT WITH THE
WORKER- IN OTHER CASES
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ARE HESITANT
TO ENGAGE- IN THE PROCESS FOR
CLEANING RESTITUTION FINES-
BECAUSE OF. THE WIDESPREAD
PRACTICE OF BUYING- AT
UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYERS TO USE
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO
INTIMIDATE WORKERS- THERE'S
LOTS OF STATE PROTOCOLS- IN IN
ORDER FOR US TO PAY A WAGE
CLAIM WE HAVE TO HAVE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS I TI N.
NUMBERS- AND OFTEN THIS GROUP
OF WORKERS IS HESITANT TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO US
SO THERE'S A LOT OF OBSTACLES
AND THAT ADDS TO THE TIME- THAT
THAT A CLAIM TAKES IN ADDITION.
TO THE OTHER- I THAT THE
COMMISSIONER OUTLINED JUST
THOUGHT THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL
TO UNDERSTANDING. VERY HELPFUL
DIRECTOR HAGEN THAT WAS MY NEXT
QUESTION IS WHY NUMBER ONE
RIGHT. AND YOU ANSWERED THAT SO
I APPRECIATE THAT- I GUESS-
WHAT YOU KNOW WHY IT TAKES SO
LONG I GUESS I SHOULD'VE
ELABORATE ON THAT WAY TAKES A
LONG. BUT I DO HAVE- BUT I
STILL HAVE A CONCERN- AND IT'S
JUST MIGHT. YOU KNOW HIGH
SCHOOL MATH I GUESS- YOU HAVE
TO EARN THIRTY FOUR PEOPLE IN
THOSE POSITIONS WITH A 32%
VACANCY WHICH LEAVES YOU A
HUNDRED SIXTY PEOPLE. AND A
HUNDRED SIXTY PEOPLE HAVE ONLY
PROCESSED. SIXTY CLAIMS IN AN
EIGHT MONTH. CYCLE ROUGHLY
BASED ON THE MATHIS IN THIS I
MEAN WHAT'S IN THE ANALYSIS
RIGHT SO IF YOU WERE PROCESS
INTO IF YOU HAD TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY CLAIMS LEFT A PROCESS
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE WAITED.
PROBABLY YEARS YEARS IN MY
RIGHT YEARS. EARLY YEARS FOR
THEIR WAGES AND YOU SEE OF
TURNER SEVENTY CLAIM STILL IN
PROCESS OR IN CLASS IN PROCESS
AS OF JULY TWENTY TWENTY YOU
HAVE A HUNDRED AND SIXTY PEOPLE
IN THE DEPARTMENT PROCESSING
THESE CLAIMS. AND YOU'RE DOWN
TO TWO OH EIGHT YOU SAID WAS
THE NUMBER. IN PROCESS. THANK
YOU SENATOR- I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST OF THESE ARE AT I DON'T
MEAN TO INTERRUPT I'M NOT
CRITICIZING I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIND OUT WHY I MEAN IN THE REAL
WORLD I OWN A BUSINESS AND OF
MY BUSINESS OPERATED LIKE THAT
I'D BE OUT OF BUSINESS SO I
JUST IT FROM YOU KNOW A
PERSPECTIVE OF TAKING CARE OF
THE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE TAKE
CARE OF BUSINESS- OUR GOAL. ARE
YOUR DEPARTMENTS GOAL MINDER
SAYS MAKE SURE THESE PEOPLE GET
PAID FOR THE WAGES THAT THEY
DID NOT RECEIVE. AN AND SO I AM
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT HOW COME IT
TAKES. HOW COME A HUNDRED SIXTY
PEOPLE CAN'T PROCESS I DON'T
KNOW. TO CLAIMS EACH IN THE
NEXT THIRTY DAYS. THANK YOU
SENATOR WHAT WE MISSED BURKE
AND I CAN PROVIDE- SPECIFIC
DETAILS FOR YOU ON THOSE
SPECIFIC- ACTIVITIES OF THE
NUMBERS YOU'RE REFERENCING I
DON'T HAVE THOSE BEFORE ME TO
DATE- IN GENERAL ARE AGENCY
PROCESSES OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
CLAIMS A YEAR. OKAY AND SO
WE'RE SPECIFICALLY I'M SIMPLY
REPORTING ON THOSE CLAIMS IN
REFERENCE TO THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURE SPECIAL ACCOUNTS.
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE MUCH
MORE DETAIL WITH YOU ON THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING
FROM JULY TWENTY TWENTY AND
EXPLAIN WHERE THEY ARE NOW IN
THE PROCESS. SO THE THIRTY
THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT YOU FILE
ARE NOT RELATED TO THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURERS. THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURERS SPECIAL ACCOUNT
CLEANS ARE PART OF THOSE THIRTY
THOUSAND CLAIMS THAT THE PUBLIC
FILES WITH US OKAY. RIGHT THANK
YOU MA'AM THANK YOU AND ANY
INFORMATION- COMMISSIONER THAT-
YOU HAVE I THINK WITH REGARDS
TO A SENATOR GROWTH. INSTANCE
ARE COMMISSION AGGRESSIVE BAR-
IT BE GREAT I THINK THE SHARE
WITH- WITH ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WELL THIS IS OUR-
YES I'M SORRY CENTER
CRITICIZING IF I CAN JUST HAS
ONE QUESTION BEFORE WE WRAP UP
IN- FOR THE COMMISSIONER.
BERMAN I KNOW YOU WERE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE JUDICATA
OF CLAIMS IN GENERAL PROTECTING
FOR THE GARMENT WORKERS
POLITICAL QUESTION COULD BE
GENERALISED TO THE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOR ALL CLAIMS AS
WELL. ONCE WE GET TO JUDICATA
AND PARTICULARLY OF THESE
CLAIMS THAT ARE. ON THE TABLE
TODAY- WHAT HAPPENS WITH
COLLECTION- WHAT X. TO WHAT
EXTENT DOES YOUR- A DEPARTMENT
OR AGENCY. ASSIST WITH
COLLECTION OF HEARD OF ALL THE
CHALLENGES OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
EITHER TRANSCEND ARE MOVING
AROUND AND SO FORTH- IN A AND-
I HAVE SOME EXPERIENCES HAVE
KERN COUNTY WITH. OF STANDING
UP OUR OWN COLLECTION EFFORTS
ON ON EDUCATED CLAIMS BUT I
WONDER IF IT. YOU KNOW. TO WHAT
EXTENT THE STATE ASSIST WITHOUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR HISTORICALLY
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
HAS NOT ENGAGED VERY
AGGRESSIVELY IN COLLECTIONS
ACTIVITIES- WE HAD A LONG
STANDING RELATIONSHIP WITH F.
T. B. WHERE WE WOULD REFER
CASES TO FTP FOR COLLECTIONS-
HOWEVER IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION SECRETARY CITU
ASK COMMISSIONER DID AN
OUTSTANDING JOB IN BUILDING
EIGHT JUDGMENT ENFORCEMENT
UNIT. THAT DID PRIORITIZE- AND
INCREASED TOOLS THAT WE RECEIVE
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE OF
FOR US TO PURSUE THE RECOVERY
OF THOSE WAGES SO WE NOW HAVE A
UNIT THAT FOCUSES ON BAT AND
SINCE I CAME AND ASKED
PERMISSION- I AM LOOKING TO
EXPAND RECOVERY IS NOT
SOMETHING WE CAN LOOK AT JUST
AT THE END OF THE PROCESS.
BECAUSE SO MANY OF THE
EMPLOYERS THAT WORKERS FILE
CLAIMS AGAINST OPERATE IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY HAVE NO
INTENTION OF FOLLOWING THE LAW
OPERATE OUT OF THEIR TRUNKS ON
THEIR CARS WORKERS DO NOT HAVE
FULL INFORMATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE CRIMINAL ELEMENT IN
OUR INDUSTRIES AND THOSE ARE
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
PURSUE SO IT'S NOT A SIMPLE
COLLECTIONS. THAT ONE WOULD
THINK IT'S MORE OF AN
ENFORCEMENT ACTION SO WE HAVE
BEEN TAKING- ADDITIONAL STEPS
MORE CREATIVE STEPS LIKE FIGHT
FILING FRAUDULENT TRANSFER
LAWSUITS OF BANK LEVEES WE MOST
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SHERIFF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. TO PURSUE
THE RECOVERY OF THE THOUSANDS
OF UNPAID JUDGMENTS WE HAVE IN
L. A. COUNTY IF THAT IS
SUCCESSFUL WE WILL APPROACH
OTHER COUNTIES TO PARTNER WITH
US AND I'D BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH MORE IN DETAILED
INFORMATION OF THEIR. RECENT
ACTIVITIES THAT WE- EAI BE
INTERESTED IN IN THE UP AND ALL
SPEECH IN HEARING. YOU KNOW FOR
EX. ON THE CONCUSSION
ENFORCEMENT WHAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES YOU NEED BEYOND WHAT
THE LEGISLATORS RECENTLY
GRANTED. I'M PRETTY SURE. CLICK
HERE DRAWS WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN KNOWING AS WELL FROM A
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT IF YOU
NEED ASSISTANCE I MEAN. GREAT
IF WE GET THROUGH THE EDUCATION
AND NO ONE SOUNDS LIKE I'M
PREACHING OF HARD TO SAY THIS
BUT GREAT IF WE GET TO THE
JUDICATA IN THEIR JUDGMENTS OUT
THERE. AND THEN WE HAVE FOLKS
WHO. CAN'T AFFORD A LAWYER UP-
THEY'RE NOT SOPHISTICATED ON
THEMSELVES ON HOW TO PLACE A
LIEN ON. AN EMPLOYER- OR OR A
GARNISHMENT ON A- ON A BANK
ACCOUNT- AND THEY NEED
ASSISTANCE- I'M FAMILIAR WITH
ALL OF THE HERO THE PROBLEMS
AND CHALLENGES WITH GOING AFTER
CERTAIN EMPLOYERS BUT I'M ALSO.
FAMILIAR WITH SOME OF THE
PRACTICES WE PUT INTO PLACE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WITH HER OWN
OFFICE OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT WHICH- WAS AN
INITIATIVE THAT I CREATED DOWN
THERE- WE'RE OUR ATTORNEYS ARE
LEGAL COUNSEL THERE- YOU KNOW.
BROUGHT BACK TO US SO A LOT
MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX THE
THAT ARE ARE VERY LEGITIMATE IN
TERMS OF- PULLING UP- HEALTH A
HEALTH DEPARTMENT LICENSES FOR
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE NON
COMPLIANT AND SO FORTH. YOU
KNOW IF THEY'VE GOT.
OUTSTANDING JUDGMENTS OF HAT
YOU'VE BROUGHT TO BEAR AT THIS
LEVEL OF THAT HAVEN'T BEEN PAID
TO THOSE WORKERS. INTO THEM AND
THEN THE ISSUE BECOMES. YOU
KNOW WHAT CAN WE THROW AT THOSE
EMPLOYERS WHO. WHO ARE IN A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN FIND THEM-
SHOULD THEY CONTINUE TO BE
LICENSED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT BY
THE STATES TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE THEIR BUSINESSES WHEN
THEY'VE- PERHAPS SO. YOU KNOW
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN. IN JUDGMENTS- TO THESE
WORKERS SO. I'D LOVE TO HEAR.%
IT'S I AM DRAW THE INFERENCE
FROM YOUR COMMENTS AT THIS
POINT THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN. THAT KIND OF AN EXPANSION
OF ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES AND
WHETHER THAT IS- A MORE ROBUST
OFFICE OF LABOR STANDS
APPORTIONMENT WITHIN YOUR OWN
OFFICE OR JUST JUST. DOLLARS
AND TOOLS TO GO TO WORK ON THAT
THAT'S WHAT I'D BE INTERESTED
IN HEARING IN AND PLEASE.
UNLESS SOMEBODY DOESN'T WANT
THAT INFORMATION I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT BEING SHARED WITH
THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR I LET ME JUST ADD-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN DEVELOPING THAT PROGRAM WE
DO HAVE A STRONG RELATIONSHIP
WITH SANTA CLARA COUNTY. BOTH
WITH THEIR HEALTH DEPARTMENT
AND THEIR LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY WE DID ENGAGE IN
AN INITIATIVE WHERE WE WERE
ABLE TO RECOVER UNPAID WAGES ON
JUDGMENTS FIFTY FIFTY OF THEM-
DUE TO THAT INITIATIVE THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WE ARE LOOKING TO.
EXPAND THAT EFFORT THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THE COMMISSION THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU OUT COMMISSIONER
GARCIA BROWER AND- DIRECTOR
KAGAN- VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
WORK. UNFORTUNATELY ALL OF THIS
IS WHAT INSPIRED ME TO
INTRODUCE. MY BILL AT THREE
SIXTY TO DO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES
ON ON WAGE THEFT AND IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY SO I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF THOSE ARE. HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN. THANK
YOU- WE MOVE ON STRIKE OUR
FINAL. FOR FINAL ISSUE FIFTEEN-
OUR STATE RETIREMENT-
LIABILITIES. SO WE HAVE. PRISON
IN HERE THE CALL PER EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND THE STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM IF
YOU WOULD PRESENT. OKAY
ANYTHING FOR A WITH A CURRENT
FINANCE ALL BECAUSE I MEAN I
DON'T- WELL CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY I SO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO USE THE ESTIMATED TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION AND PROPOSITIONS.
FUNDING AVAILABLE OF THAT YEAR
TO MAKE THREE ONE TIME
PAYMENTS. ARE THE FIRST ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS A
LITTLE CONTAINER. FOR ITS BE
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES THAT THE
STATE PLANS I CALPERS. HI THIS
IS EIGHT NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLAR. PAYMENT
TOWARDS THE STATE'S RETIREE
HEALTH UNFUNDED LIABILITIES OF
WHICH SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION WILL BE INTENDED TO
MAKE UP FOR THE- EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATE. OKAY EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE SUSPENDED AS
A RESULT OF THE PERSONALLY
PROGRAM A CURRENT YEAR. AND
FINALLY A FOUR HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF ALL PENSION
PAYMENT. TOWARDS THE STATE'S
SHARE UNFUNDED. LIABILITIES
FORECASTERS. I MENTION I BY MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I WELL AS FROM FROM
CALPERS AND CAL STAR THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU HAVE. OKAY DOES THE L. A.
HAVING COMMON OR COMMENTS. YES
GOOD MORNING- I'M MADAM
CHAIRMAN SENATORS MANAGE NICK
SCHROEDER WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS THE AGENDA
INDICATES. WE THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL HAS
MERIT AND IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE
LAST YEAR THAT PROPOSITION TO
FUNDS BE USED. TO ACCELERATE
PAYMENTS OF- UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES ANOTHER RETIREMENT
LIABILITY SO THAT THE FUNDING
PLANS FOR THESE BENEFITS ARE
THESE ON FOR LIABILITIES CAN
STAY ON TRACK TO BE PAID DOWN-
BY THE MID TWENTY FORTIES- THAT
BEING SAID TO BE PRECISE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS OF PROPOSITION TWO. IS
REALLY- DEPENDS ON THE REVENUE
LEVELS IN ANY GIVEN YEAR AND
BECAUSE OF THAT- WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HOLD ANY
PROPOSAL RELATED PROPOSITION TO
OPEN UNTIL LATER IN THE PROCESS
WHEN. WE HAVE MORE INFORMATION
AND- YOU KNOW BETTER VIEW OF
WHAT OUR REVENUE OUTLOOK. MIGHT
LOOK LIKE IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
OKAY CENTERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS NO
HEARING NONE OKAY WE WILL NOW-
I DON'T EITHER WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN MY RIGHT YES
OKAY SO ANYONE WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR MAY IS A
TWO TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING CALM. COMMENT KEEP
THERE MIGHT REMARKS TO WITHIN
ONE MINUTE. NOW LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM I SEE NONE. I
DON'T SEE ANY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEEN NONE. OF WE WILL
NOW I'LL MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ACTUALLY I HAVE ONE
IN KIEL OKAY NINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTY ABOUT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT COMMENT ON TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF. BETTER JOBS AND
HIGHER WAGES BUT DO NOTE FOR
THE RECORD THAT WE AGREE WITH
THE COMMITTEE. A SEARCH OF A
BETTER NAME MIGHT BE.
UNFAVORABLE WE DO APPRECIATE
THEIR MISSIONS OF THE PROPOSAL
AND THEN ALSO JUST TO MAKE A
STATEMENT IN SUPPORT OF.
FIREFIGHTER PRETTY PRECIOUS
ACADEMIES THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED
IN THE PAST THROUGH OUR
WORKFORCE MONIES THROUGH THE
DIVISION OF THE PROJECT
STANDARD. WITH NEARLY CRUSHING.
COMMITTING AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION CONSIDERATIONS
THANKS FOR IN. THE MARKET NAY
REVISED PROPOSED SUPPORT.
ENEMIES GET A REPRESENTED. A
PEOPLE IN. BNP ONE THIRD AND
PARAMEDIC LEYSIN TO PROVIDE THE
AT THE THAT TO HELP GET THEM IN
TO THE FIRE SERVICE AND
DIVERSIY OUR WORKFORCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU. MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE IN Q.
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
BOLLINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ETP IN JOBS MY
COMMENTS ARE IN RELATION TO
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN AND
SPECIFICALLY THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL. OUR COALITION
SUPPORT JOB TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIPS AND CAREER
ADVANCEMENT FOR LABOR.
BUSINESSES AND EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WITH OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS SIGNED ON IN
SUPPORT OF OUR EFFORTS. NO
POSITION ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
BETTER JOBS AND HIGHER WAGES
FREE ALIGNMENT. HOWEVER WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED WITH A
PROPOSED 20% PASSED. THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL.
MINISTRATION OF YOUR MARKET
ISSUE OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. IN YET
P. P. FACES THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS CASH. ETP'S ROLES
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMY MOVING
LARGE NUMBERS OF EMPLOYEES
WORKERS. QUICKLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT IN SAVING THE JOBS
OF WORKERS THREATENED WITH
DISPLACEMENT. WE CANNOT THINK
OF A MORE WORTHWHILE
INVESTMENTS GIVEN THE ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY OUR STATE FACING.
AS SUCH WE ARE REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ETP IN THIS YEAR'S.
BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MADHUR.
FOR MARTIN YOU RIGHT. FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS A MORNING MR.
CALIFORNIA'S AND ASSOCIATION
WE'D LIKE TO GET COMMENTS ON
ISSUE NUMBER TEN AND WE'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO
EXPAND AND DEVELOP THE
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
EVEN BEFORE THE CALL THE
NINETEEN TEN TO MAKE MANY
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
SUFFERING FROM A SHORTAGE OF
DENTAL ASSISTANT COOK
PROJECTIONS. INDICATING WITH
THAT WE NEED AT LEAST. NINE
THOUSAND YOU CAN PUT THIS IS BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. I WILL
HAVE DATA FROM EACH THAT
CURRENTLY SHOW THAT DENTAL
OFFICES ARE OPERATING AT ABOUT
85% I THINK IT HAS TO BE. THE
DENTAL SECTOR WHICH IS.
UNDERSTAFFED BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IS STILL DOWN ABOUT
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND TOTAL DROPS
TO GET THE PRETENDING LIKE
LEVEL. WELL WE KNOW THAT NOT
ALL OF THESE JOBS CAN BE FILLED
WITH EMPLOYEES THAT ARE NEW TO
THE DENTAL PROFESSION.
ESTIMATED THAT A THIRD TO ONE
HALF OF THOSE VACANCIES COULD
BE FILLED WITH EMPLOYEES ARE
DISPLACED FROM OTHER INDUSTRY.
OR THINKING YOUR CAREERS. WHICH
IS WHY WE ARE- PROPONENTS. I
WORK WITH KNOWLEDGE ROGRAM WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
DELTA DENTAL AND OTHER LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
FLUSH OUT SHOVEL READY
PROPOSALS. AND THAT INCLUDES A
COMBINATION OF HEAT ON THE JOB
TRAINING- EFFORTS WE NEED A
CLASSROOM TRAINING COMPONENT
THANK YOU CAN WRITE EDUCATION
FOR THE LIFE OF THE PROGRAM.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD YOU WORK
WITH LEGISLATURE ON MANY ISSUES
THANK. YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MONTEREY THANK YOU
ARE PAINFULLY GO AHEAD. HI
DAISY ON VALENTINE MEN
ORGANIZER WITH THE GARMENT
WORKERS CENTER I WAS JUST
CALLING ON THEM TO STAY THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF THE INFORMATION
ON THAT GARMENTS ARE
RESTITUTION FINES- WORKERS ARE
STILL CONTINUING TO WAIT AND-
REALLY THAT DILUTION IS SB
SIXTY TWO AND- LEGISLATION IS
IMPORTANT TO US BY NAME
CONCRETE SOLUTIONS- AT THAT IF.
YOU'RE IN BY THOUSANDS OF
WORKERSEVERY DAY AND YOU ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
TO PRODUCE WRAPPED HOSPITAL
ROAD AND CONTRACTING COALBED-
SO THIS IS THE ESSENTIAL
LEGISLATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
PASSED YOUR- THERE WILL BE SOME
GARMENT WRKERS HOPEFULLY THEY
FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET ON TO
THE QUEUE. AND YOUR COMPUTER.
AT PLEASE AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
AN OTHERS THANK YOU. I HAVE SIX
THANK YOU OVER MY TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JIMMY GAROPPOLO AT BETULINIC
LEGAL SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES
I'M JUST GOING TO SPEAK ON THE
ISSUE FOURTEEN THE GOVERNMENT
RESTITUTION FINES THANK YOU FOR
DISCUSSING IT THIS MORNING AND
FOR THE INFORMATION YOU SHARE
TODAY. I WANT TO REITERATE HOW
IMPORTANT LEVINE USED GARMENT
WORKERS AND HOW IT SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY TO MAKE SURE IT IS
ADEQUATELY FUNDED AND I CLAIMS
ARE PAID OUT IN A TIMELY
FASHION. THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED WAGE THAT IS
EXTREMELY WIDESPREAD IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND THE RESTITUTION
FUND IS VITAL TO HELP CORRECT
BETTER JUSTICE WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
THAT GOVERNMENT WORKERS WAGE
CLAIMS ARE PAID OUT IN FULL AND
PROCESS QUICKLY. THANK YOU ALL
FOR DOING YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS. VITAL ISSUE AND FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
RIGHT TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
NOT AVAILABLE SHARE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION I'M CALLING IN
BEFORE AND TO BE ON ITEM
FOURTEEN THE CAR AND YOU GOT
YOUR SPECIAL ACCOUNT THAT THE
ECHO WHAT IS DONE PREVIOUSLY SB
FIFTY TWO WOULD TAKE A VITAL
STEP TOWARDS ENSURING ADEQUATE
PROTECTION FOR THE WILL BE A
GARMENT WORKER IF YOU HAVE
BEEN. WORKING CONSTANTLY DROP
OF ENDEMIC THAT HELP PROVIDE TV
AND LIVE OFF OF FABRIC YOUR
LONG HISTORY OF WAGE THAT FELL
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
INFORMATION YOU PROVIDED. AND-
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LOCAL GOOGLE NO. DO YOU
REMEMBER I. REMEMBER IN THE DAY
FINANCING PLAN THANK YOU HELLO
HELLO FOR THINGS THAT I KNOW
HIM FROM OUTSIDE OF WHAT THE
IN. YEAH I THINK THE ONLY A
LITTLE MORE THAN A LOT OF THE
REST OF THE FAMILY LAURA FOR
NEARLY NINE MILLION. INSIGHT
AFTER THE MAXIMUM. SOMEBODY IT
ALMOST SOME IN A GRANT FORM
LOVE. THEM YEAH. GLASSES THE
HIGH MINIMUM THE BOCA. HI MY
NAME IS THIS ABOUT AND I BEEN
WORKING WITH IN THE PREPARE
YEARS AND I'VE SUFFERED A LOT
OF WEIGHT- DO THE INDUSTRY WE
NEED SB SIXTY TWO TO POWER AND
WE ALL ARE FOR EVERYBODY THAT'S
ALL FROM THE BAR WORK. FUND TO
BE BANGALORE. NUMBER FOR THE
FOLLOWING BEYOND. THE MODEL
THAT HAND. OF PEOPLE THOUGHT
PHONE NUMBER A LOT CAN LUCK
WITH THAT'S. WELL DON'T LIKE
LEVEL COACH AND THEN. BLACKROCK
MATHIS MY NAME IS KRISTA GARCIA
I'VE BEEN FOR THREE YEAR IN THE
ARMY INDUSTRY I'VE- WAIT STEP
I'M BEHALF OF BACKING- WE ARE
LOOKING. FOR SUPPORT OF LEAD TO
THAT THE A SIXTY BUT WE ALSO
LOOKING FOR EVERYBODY TO BE
PAID FROM THE GARMENT WORKER TO
SHOW ON THE YOU SECONDS HERE
WHAT PRO SAID. MINAMATA MY IDEA
INCOME AND NON BUT THEN IT'S
GOING BUT I HOW IN THE BUT I
CAN EFFECT IN TAKE THAT IF
GOING. NUMBER INPUT INPUT CYLON
DEAL THEY THEY ALL DIFFERENT
DANIEL HONDA DURING THE THREE
HUNDRED OF COURSE A- IN AT THE
HE FOUND UP FOR A WIN IS LET
HIM MORE PRODUCTIVELY THAT FROM
A LITTLE OF THIS AND TO GO. OF
AFTER THE A LAKE IT'S A THIS IS
A BY EAGLE IF I'M BEING ADDED
ON KID IN MOST LOST BY AN AND A
PHONE OF A CO. AND ALSO FOR
EVERYBODY TO BE PAID FROM. THE-
BERMAN RESTITUTION BY THE
ARMENIA. ONLY NUMBER ONE IS THE
OTHER END OF THE LAST. WE ARE
SIMPLY. THAT IS NOT HAPPENING
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW ENOUGH
CONSIDERING JACKSON DAN. M. A
LOT ABOUT THE FOR AFTER BUT IN
A LATE INTO THEY DON'T FIVE
LAST KNOW WHAT IT. OKAY MORE.
BUYING. ONE MY NAME IS THEIR
MEDIA AND WORKING IN THE
GARMENT IN THE FOR YEAR- WE SAW
A LOT OF THAT IN THE GARMENT IN
THE I'M A MEMBER OF THE GARMENT
OR CENTER AND WE ALSO NEED
EVERYWHERE TO BE FROM THE REST
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU READY
VERY MUCH MY NAME GOT INTO. I'M
IN OREGON. WITH THE GARMIN
WORKERS- ON THE- OF ALL THE
GOVERNMENT WORKERS HERE AUSTIN.
I WANT TO THANK THE- PAUL BE.
THERE CAN'T BE WORKER- WE
DEFINITELY. HAVE MANY. FOLKS
THE WAY FOR PAY TO GO RESEARCH.
FOR AND DUE TO A COLD. AND DUE
TO THE SHUTDOWN OF THE INTO.
REALLY WAITING FOR PAYING
DELIVERY. CAN YOU GET PAID FROM
THE CARMEN RECURSOS FROM
BECAUSE FACTORY OWNER STEPS
AWAY FROM THE RESPONSE OF
PAYING THE WORK SO WE REALLY
REALLY FAST FOR- BERMAN RICKY
FONG PART MAKING THE WORKERS%
HOLE YOU CAN BRING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD ASSET
AT THOSE. MODER DO WE HAVE ANY.
WE SHOULD DO THANK YOU I AM
THREE LASTING RYAN TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I
CHAIR MEMBERS PRIVILEGED UP AND
THEY HAVE THE CENTER FOR PLANO
OPPORTUNITIES- ECONOMY A QUICK
CALL I MADE CONVENE LOOK AT FOR
THE FORTY AFTER. AND PUT THAT
ON THOSE ARE EIGHT THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS RE ENTRY POPULAR.
DURANTE IN AMONG THE MOST
AFFORDABLE THE BILL IN WORKER.
THEIR DIVORCE LABEL LATINO AND
PEOPLE COME EXPERIENCE IN MY
AND BY A IN THE MARKET MANY OF
THOSE RETURNING FROM INCOME.
THE OF THE CONTENT BUT HI AND
RATE HIGHER RATES OF POORLY
NINETEEN TRY HELPFUL. I THINK
THE CONTENT. AND I WILL LOOK
FOR TO WITH TWENTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD- THE MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON- NOT A CHAIR ARE
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORED WILL
BLESS YOUR BEEN A LONG POVERTY.
THIS TACKLE THE- AND FROM THE
PREVIOUS CALL ARE LIKE TO SHOW
OFF FOURTEEN AND THE GOVERNMENT
WORK RESTITUTION FOR OF THE TWO
CRITICAL RESOURCE DONALD. WHO
ARE NEED TO- OF THIS BUG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I'M
TRYING SIX PLEASE CALL. THE
STARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FOR MISTER SPEAKER
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSALS
OUTLINED IN ISSUE THIRTEEN TO
IMPROVE SOME OF THE STAFFING
STRUGGLES AT CAL OSHA IT'S
REALLY BEEN A MAJOR CONCERN
WITH OUR WORKER HEALTH AND
SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A
LONG TIME AND THIS- ALL THESE
VACANCIES HOW PERSISTENT
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY LIES AT THE
HEART OF A VARIETY OF OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT'S SORT OF THE
WE'VE GOT TRYING TO KEEP
WORKERS SAFE ON THE JOB AND IF
WE CAN. MAKE MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS TOWARDS THIS AS
OUTLINED IN THIS PROPOSAL WE
THINK IT WILL DIRECTLY HELP
SOLVE A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT ARE CONNECTED TO
IT STRONGLY. URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
SAID HE. BUT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
MUSICAL. THE LAST. MAYBE IT
WILL BE. OKAY HELLO. THANKS.
ULLAH. TAKE A LOOK OKAY- WHAT
MADE THEM DIFFERENT GOING TOLD
I'M HERE FOR THE- GARMENT LOOK
AT CENTER. AND- AND I'M ABOUT
THE AD I SEVEN. FIFTY AND I
HAVE EXPERIENCE WHAT DO YOU FOR
MANY YEARS AND I HOW WORKING
YEARS AND I HAVE BEEN PICKING
IT UP BEFORE THE BEAST
BREAKCORE ARE YOU KNOW IN THE
LOWEST PRICE STATE NEVER HIM.
NEXT YEAR ABOUT SEVEN FIVE SAY
STE QUORUM DIFFICULT- OPERATOR
THERE HOW TO DO. FOLLOW THE
THAT. WORK. IN OUR LAST WEEK OF
THE WILL HELP WORK AROUND.
SIXTY A WEEK NOT EVEN BE ABLE
TO- TOOLS- THIRD MINIMUM. AND
YET IN THE IN THE AND I MUST DO
SO OF WAR WAITING BORDERS ON
MONEY. WELL I ME SAY IT AGAIN
WE GET THE RIGHT NOW TO YES I
THOUGHT SO THEN THEY MAY NOT
THOUGH. OKAY YES WHICH IS ASK
AS TO THE MONEY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE CURE JUST BE MOMENT
FOR THEIR Y. BAKKALI DID DROP I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- SEPARATION DATE OUT
BACK AND I HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENTING Q. OKAY. BY TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THIS COMEDIAN DURING I WANTED
TO SPECIFICALLY COMMENT ON ITEM
FOURTEEN IN RELATIONSHIP THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET WHICH INCLUDES
THAT THAT STATE CONTRIBUTION.
THAT WERE CREATED UNDER AB
COURTS ONE SIXTY NINE CAN MOVE
PALLISTER'S TOWARDS FULL
FUNDING AS WELL AS TO ATTRACT A
SMALL GAP THAT WAS CREATED IN
THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WE
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
COMMITMENT THAT THE.
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED. KEEP
TEACHERS RETIRED SYSTEM
COLLEAGUES IN LOOK FOR THE
FUTURE COMMERCE WITH YOUR THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR ANY FAILURE I. YES I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. CAN
YOU PLEASE. TRY ONCE MORE. IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE- MODERATOR-
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SENATORS
DO YOU HAVE ANY. FINAL EDITION
OF QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. NO
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY
ITEMS AND WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
IN THREE GROUPS OF BOATS- THE
FIRST VOTE WILL BE ON ISSUES.
ONE TWO THREE SIX AND SEVEN.
ONE TWO THREE SIX AND SEVEN. TO
HAVE A MOTION SO MOVED. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROVE WELL THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER STRAWSER I CRAZY GROWTH
HI NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. WITH WHAT
IS THE FINAL VOTE FOR
FOURTEENTH. WE'RE FOUR FOUR TWO
ZERO OKAY THE SECOND OF VOTE
WILL BE ON ISSUE FOR BY ITSELF.
YOU HAVE A MOTION THE- MOVE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN OF WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND-
STROTHER HI DAISY I GROWTH
STAINED NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. THREE
ONE THREE AND THE VOTE IS THREE
TO ONE. I'M SORRY THREE ZERO
OKAY THAT'S THE FINAL VOTE THE
FINAL VOTE WILL BE ON ISSUES
FIVE AND EIGHT. TO HAVE A
MOTION ON THESE ISSUES TO
APPROVED STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION. THE MOVE- BY
SENATOR NEWMAN WELL THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RAZA HI IS A ROVE NO LIMON ALL
RIGHT. FORTY THREE TO ONE-
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE POINT TO US WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
AND OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. AND WE HAVE NOW
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THIS OP
COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU COLLEAGUES